Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt.
Mein Name ist Tim Pridlaw und ich begrüße alle zur Ausgabe 131 von UKW.
Ja, in relativ schneller Folge nach der letzten Sendung mit Pavel über die Ukraine.
Hat auch einen Grund. Hatte ich auch schon so nebenbei ein bisschen angekündigt,
denn ich wollte mich heute nochmal über Ukraine unterhalten und zwar mit dem Enno. Hallo Enno.
Hallo Tim.
Herzlich willkommen bei UKW und wieder zurück ist eine Weile her,
dass wir miteinander gesprochen haben.
Ich habe es jetzt gerade gar nicht nachgeschlagen, wann das war.
Das war im Oktober 2024 und das war ja dein Bericht aus, ja von der Ostfront
sozusagen in der Ukraine war.
Genau, du warst in Pokrovsk und die Stadt, die auch immer noch nicht gefallen
ist, wenn sie auch gleich immer noch stark belagert ist.
Da habe ich dich ja sehr beneidet um diese Reise. Es ist ja nicht ganz so einfach,
da überhaupt hingelassen zu werden, während man ja den Rest der Ukraine eigentlich
easy bereisen kann. Ich weiß gar nicht, wo ist die Grenze?
Wie nah darf man quasi?
Ja, ein bisschen hinter Rakiv, also man fährt so Kiew, Rakiv biegt nach unten
ab und dann so bei Isum etwa, da so mehr oder minder.
Also so 30 bis 50 Kilometer von der Front?
Genau, so grob.
So eine Artillerie-Länge sozusagen.
Genau, also genau so ein bisschen mehr, so falls die sich bewegen,
dass man immer noch sicher ist. Aber das scheint mir auch allgemein so grob
die Länge, also so 30 bis 50 Kilometer.
Und dann kommt es halt auch ein bisschen darauf an, wo es eine Brücke,
die man gut überblicken kann. Oder da in Isium gibt es so eine T-Kreuzung.
Das mag trivial aussehen, aber wo es in die relevanten Richtungen geht.
Also mir scheint so da, wo halt ein praktischer Punkt ist in der Nähe,
da wird man dann doch intensiver gefragt.
Und dann so direkt vor Kramatorsk in dem Fall, da ist dann sowas wie die harte
Grenze, wo die dann sagen, wenn du hier nicht hingehörst und wir nicht wissen,
wer du bist, dann darfst du hier leider nicht rein.
Ja, ja. Na gut, jetzt sind also fünf Monate vergangen seit unserem letzten Gespräch.
Da ist ja eine Menge passiert.
Die Wahl war ja schon gelaufen, aber jetzt sehen wir ja gerade,
was alles abgeht in den USA und ich glaube, es ist alles noch ein bisschen schlimmer,
als man so hätte befürchten können.
Aber bevor wir das alles noch beleuchten aus der Perspektive der Ukraine,
weil du warst ja jetzt sozusagen nochmal vor Ort, das ist jetzt so ein bisschen
der Anlass, warum ich nochmal mit dir sprechen wollte,
möchte ich aber gerne nochmal erstmal ein bisschen noch weiter südlich schauen
und zwar auf die Situation in Syrien.
Da habe ich mich mit Pawel ja auch schon drüber unterhalten,
weil ich denke, dass das alles so ein bisschen Relevanz hat.
Dort gab es halt Revolution, quasi kurz nach unserem Gespräch und seitdem dort
die Assad-Regierung gestürzt wurde,
ist es immerhin verhältnismäßig ruhig geblieben in dem Land, muss man sagen.
Es gab zwar jetzt jüngst vor einer Woche oder zwei gab es nochmal so Aufstände
und leider auch viele Tote.
Ich habe nicht ganz geblickt, was da die Situation war, aber im Wesentlichen
gibt es halt immer wieder noch so alte Anhänger von Assad, die Ärger machen.
Und am Ende ist es natürlich auch nicht so einfach, so ein Kriegsheer,
was man losgeschickt hat, dann in so Friedenszeiten auch so ohne weiteres stabil
zu halten, dass sie nicht sofort wieder durchdrehen, wenn es mal irgendwo ruckelt.
So würde ich das mal interpretieren, was da passiert ist. Aber im Großen und
Ganzen, muss man sagen, scheint dem, ja wie heißt er denn jetzt?
Also ich heiße jetzt Al-Jolani, habe ich mir jetzt gemerkt, aber er hat sich
ja jetzt umbenannt oder zurückbenannt.
Ja, Ahmed Al-Shara, also Al-Shara.
Genau, Ahmed Al-Shara.
Ja, aber ich kenne ihn auch als Jolani, Golani, genau.
Ja, das war so ein bisschen sein Kampf oder alter Name, wie auch immer.
Auf jeden Fall ist er ja der Anführer gewesen, dieser HTS-Rebellen,
die im Wesentlichen für den Umsturz dann verantwortlich waren.
Das war alles gut geplant, das hatte ein gutes Timing.
Und jetzt hat er sich zum vorübergehenden Präsidenten machen lassen,
was sicherlich ganz sinnvoll ist, weil sich ja in ihm sozusagen auch das ganze
Vertrauen in das aktuelle System so ein bisschen manifestiert.
Und ich finde, er macht einen relativ gemäßigten und durchdachten Eindruck.
Ich habe mir ein Interview mit ihm angeschaut bei The Rest is Politics.
Das war alles schon sehr staatsmännisch, was darüber kam.
Und es scheint mir auch so, als ob er grundsätzlich an diesem Prinzip der syrischen
Einheit festhält und sehr darauf bedacht ist, jetzt mit allen Beteiligten erstmal
so einen Modus operandi zu finden.
Ja, also das scheint mir auch. also sagen wir, er weiß, wie er sich verkauft
also ob man ihm trauen kann, weiß ich immer noch nicht,
oder sagen wir, was heißt, weiß ich nicht ich traue ihm echt keinen Meter also
irgendwie das mit diesem ich bin ein ex-islamistischer Terrorist erinnert mich
immer an Monty Pite mit dem Ex-Lepra-Kranken der darum läuft und sagt ja,
eine Spende für einen Ex-Lepra-Kranken,
ich bin jetzt geheilt deswegen sieht man nichts mehr,
und so ein bisschen auch so mit, ich bin ein ex-islamistischer Terrorist.
Okay, so ein bisschen ISIS, Al-Qaida und so überall ein bisschen,
aber Schwamm drüber, das ist ja ein paar Jahre her.
Und deswegen, also sagen wir mal so, ich traue ihm nicht, aber er versteht,
wie man das Spiel spielt.
Und ich meine, er kennt die Amis gut, er hat zehn Jahre bei denen im Bau gesessen,
hat da ja auch lustigerweise dann den ISIS-Führer kennengelernt,
also so als Knastbruder quasi, Weil er mit Bagdadi zusammen da rumsaß.
Und ja, was ich mir halt denke ist, der hat der Durchblick Politik und die anderen Länder.
Und was er jetzt will, vermute ich, ist genau was du sagst, das Land einen.
Ich bin mir nicht mal sicher, ob es ihm richtiges Anliegen ist,
aber es ist halt der Weg zur Macht oder zum Machterhalt. Also Macht hat er jetzt
ja, jetzt muss er die verfestigen.
Und wenn man ein halbwegs stabiles Syrien verkauft, dann kommt aus meiner Sicht
erst der relevante Punkt, in den es geht, nämlich Geld.
Weil dann kann man sagen, Leute, wir helfen euch, die Flüchtlinge zurückzuholen
und wir halten das Land stabil, aber wir brauchen eine Entwicklungshilfe, große.
Und wenn er das Spiel jetzt richtig spielt und dann sagt, ja,
in fünf Jahren sind Wahlen,
ah, wir konnten die Wahlzettel nicht bestellen, vielleicht in zehn Jahren, in 20 Jahren,
dann glaube ich, würde die ganze Welt das mitspielen und ihn da ewigen Präsidenten
sein lassen, solange er das so okay managt und auch wenn so Sachen passieren wie Massaker jetzt,
wenn er halbwegs glaubwürdig was gegen tut oder so.
Das fehlt mir gerade auch ein bisschen, aber im Großen und Ganzen scheint mir
auch, der hat verstanden, wie internationale Politik geht und wie er Syrien
jetzt mit seinen Buddies irgendwie so als Vehikel benutzen kann.
Und wenn dann die Türkei im Norden ein Stück abgräbt und Israel im Süden und
so, ich glaube, dann ist ihm das auch nicht ganz so wichtig,
solange es dann stabil ist und solange halt nicht da die ganze Zeit ein Konflikt
ist. Also zumindest ist das mein Eindruck bisher.
Naja, so ganz frei von Vertrauen scheint er nicht zu sein.
Also scheinen einige Leute ihm zumindest so weit zu trauen, dass sie sich mit
ihm einigen. Unter anderem halt auch die, jetzt muss ich aufpassen,
dass ich mit meinen Abkürzungen nicht durcheinander komme, die SDF.
Also vielleicht nochmal kurz zur Ordnung, weil das wird jetzt öfter sein.
Es gab im Prinzip zum Zeitpunkt des Ausbruchs dieser Kämpfe so im Wesentlichen vier Gruppen.
Also einerseits die Armee von Assad, dann gab es halt HTS, der Al-Shara eben
quasi Vorstand, die so aus dem türkeinahen, auch türkisch geprägten Bereich
des Nordens vorgestoßen ist.
Dann gab es die SDF, das ist also die syrische demokratische Fraktion,
die halt im Wesentlichen im Osten des Landes ist und weitgehend durch die kurdische
Bevölkerung geprägt ist, nicht ausschließlich,
aber im Wesentlichen und im Norden noch die von der Türkei unterstützte SPD.
Hast du es drauf, die Abkürzung?
Ich bringe die mal mit der HTS durcheinander, weil die irgendwie am Ende ist alles das Gleiche.
Ja genau, also auf jeden Fall eine weitere von der Türkei stärker unterstützte Fraktion,
die halt sich dort auch einige Gefechte mit den Kurden im Norden geleistet hat.
Und da weiß ich auch gar nicht, wie es ausgeht.
Also wir haben hier so verschiedene Konflikte und jetzt ist es aber zumindest,
gab es eine Einigung zwischen der SDF, also der kürnischen Abteilung quasi innerhalb
Syriens und Al-Shara, die im Prinzip besagt,
alle bewaffneten Gruppen innerhalb Syriens werden jetzt unter einem gemeinsamen
Kommando zusammengeführt und es gibt sozusagen nur noch eine syrische Armee.
Die sich aus all diesen Gruppen zusammensetzt. Das hat mich ein bisschen überrascht,
dass das so schnell von der Hand ging.
Was ist denn da so dein Blick auf die Rolle der Kurden und die Position von
Kurdistan auf die Situation in Syrien jetzt?
Ja, also das erste Problem ist ja, so wie immer beim Nahostkonflikt,
je weiter man guckt, desto mehr Gruppen gibt es.
Und halt auch mit den Kurden ist es so, es gibt halt diese, also die kurdische
Gruppe YPG, die halt die sozusagen die dominierende Gruppe in der SDF ist.
Aber mit den Kurden in Kurdistan, Irak können die gar nicht gut und haben nicht
viel miteinander zu tun.
Also so deswegen, selbst wenn jetzt Kurdistan nimmt, sobald diese Staatsgrenze
kommt, hast du wieder zwei Kurdistans.
Und nur um das Thema nicht ewig rumzueiern, aber ganz grob gesagt,
die Kurden in Kurdistan, Irak sind halt relativ demokratisch mit Wahlen und kapitalistisch.
Und die in Syrien, das ist lustig, weil es ja die Zurich Democratic Forces sind,
aber die Kurden haben es da nicht mit anderen Parteien, Wahlen oder Pressefreiheit.
Also es gibt schon Wahlen, aber nur von einer Partei.
Das macht das dann einfacher. Dann ist das nicht so kompliziert auf dem Wahlzettel.
Und deswegen also bei Kurdistan Syrien, das ist auch aus meiner Sicht sehr schade.
Die haben echt gut gegen den IS gekämpft und das sind motivierte und gute Leute.
Aber sozusagen, wenn es dann auf die politische Ebene hochgeht,
dann hast du halt wie immer eine Handvoll Leute, die Macht erhalten wollen und
auch deswegen nicht so heiß sind auf Wahlen und sowas.
Und was die aber auch schon mit Assad hatten, an sich wollen die ihre Ruhe.
Also wenn man die da in Ruhe lässt in ihrem Bereich, der auch großteils kurdisch besiedelt ist.
Also die wollen jetzt nicht Gegenden, in denen keine Kurden sind.
Oder die sagen jetzt nicht, wir wollen Damaskus, sondern sagen,
hey, da, wo wir mehrheitlich sind, das hätten wir gern und hätten unsere Ruhe.
Und wenn ihr uns in Ruhe lasst, lassen wir euch in Ruhe und alle sind glücklich.
Eigentlich super simpel, würde ich denken, mit den Deals zu machen.
Und klar, dann gibt es in den Randbereichen Gegenden, da wohnen ein paar mehr
Araber oder ein paar mehr Kurden, es gab auch nie groß Probleme, das ist so,
okay, läuft so und deswegen denke ich, wenn du als neuer Machthaber hinkommst
und sagst, pass auf wir machen im Prinzip den Deal wie vorher, nur ohne einen Diktator.
Und ihr könnt euer Ding machen, wie, was weiß ich, wie es dann im Detail wird,
wie ein Bundesland oder was weiß ich was und wir machen unser Ding,
aber der entscheidende Punkt, den du ja hattest war, die bewaffneten Kräfte.
Und das ist, glaube ich, auch aus deutscher Sicht immer ein bisschen schwierig
zu verstehen, weil klar, wir haben eine Bundeswehr, wir haben verschiedene Polizeien,
aber die am Ende unter einer Verwaltung einer demokratischen stehen in verschiedenen Bundesländern.
Und das ist okay und funktioniert, weil wir halt in einer ruhigen Gegend leben.
Und da ist es so, die Waffen abzugeben, hat sich für die allermeisten Leute
da immer als schlecht erwiesen.
Oder umgekehrt, ich glaube, es gab nicht einen Fall, so im Nahen Osten,
wo eine Gruppe gesagt hat, jo, ich gebe, also ich lege die Waffen nieder und
das war positiv für sie am Ende so im Long Run.
Und das ist so ein bisschen, deswegen sind die da so empfindlich.
Also wenn Machthaber kommt und sagt, wir machen jetzt alle eine Armee,
dann sagen alle, warte, warte, warte.
Also wir können gerne hier einen Deal machen und wir können in Frieden zusammenwohnen
und so, aber unsere Waffen oder unsere Kontrolle über Waffen,
über die Armee, das ist halt so,
also das ergibt Totalsinn, wenn man den Staat organisieren will,
aber ich glaube, das wird ein ganz, ganz großer Knackpunkt.
Ein bisschen was ähnliches gibt es in Kurdistan, Irak oder im Irak allgemein.
Das war die Kurden, die formal zur irakischen Armee gehören seit 2005.
Aber nicht ein irakischer Minister oder General hat irgendwas über die kurdische Armee zu sagen.
Also de facto sind es zwei völlig getrennte Sachen, aber auf dem Papier gehören sie dazu.
Und das war so der Deal, den man da gefunden hat. Weil dann können die Kurden
sagen, wir haben es Ja, das ist ja in der Hand.
Und die Iraker können sagen, aber wir haben eine Armee und alle sind so halbwegs zufrieden damit.
Und deswegen, das könnte, denke ich, in Syrien schwierig werden,
je nachdem, wie hart man das durchziehen will.
Wenn man auch so ein Deal findet und sagt, liebe Kurden, solange ihr bei so
Kalaschnikows und so kleinen Granatwerfern bleibt...
Könnt ihr da treiben, was ihr wollt. Aber nicht, dass sie jetzt anfangen mit
Kampfjets oder Mittelstreckenraketen oder so.
Also sozusagen, dass du sie auf einem bewaffneten Niveau lässt,
dass sie ihre Dörfer verteidigen können, wenn sowas wie der IS kommt.
Aber halt nicht, dass sie wie eine reguläre Armee sich aufrüsten dürfen.
Schließt das Panzer schon mit ein?
Ja, so grenzwertig. Also ich glaube, der Punkt ist, die haben quasi keine.
Also auch die Kurden in den verschiedenen Gegenden, die haben,
was weiß ich, da taucht dann mal echt so ein T-62 oder so auf,
als hättest du den aus dem Museum geklaut.
Also so ein alter russischer Panzer, der nicht mehr aktuell ist.
Ja, genau so 60 Jahre alt. Also der auch, sagen wir von allen Aspekten her,
das ist so wie wenn du mit dem Fiat Panda zur Formel 1 kommst und sagst,
hey, ein Auto ist ein Auto und alle sagen, du darfst mitspielen, das ist schon okay.
Aber sagen wir mal, also ich würde denken, das ist so ein bisschen,
das könnte ein Knackpunkt sein, je nachdem, ob da einer von beiden sozusagen
den starken Mann machen will und sagt, ich drücke jetzt meine Meinung durch.
Aber bisher habe ich das Gefühl, dass die da auch ganz schlau sind und dass
so auch die Verhandlungsführer da, was es da gibt, offensichtlich läuft das
ja ganz geschmeidig hinter verschlossenen Türen.
Also jetzt nur mal zum Vergleich, als wir hier mit den Politikern in Deutschland
diese Corona-Sitzung hatten, da hatten wir ja quasi in Echtzeit in allen Medien,
was hat der gesagt und was hat der gesagt.
Und jetzt gibt es in Syrien offensichtlich ja so Leute von den verschiedenen
Fraktionen, die miteinander sprechen.
Und das ist jetzt nicht so, dass man das Gefühl hat, dass da viel geleakt wird
oder das stressig ist. Also mir scheint bisher, alle machen es professionell.
Aber der Punkt mit, wer hat die Kontrolle über Waffen, sagen wir mal,
muss man vorsichtig spielen.
Und auch ein Punkt ist ja.
Niemand will eigentlich große Waffen irgendwo in Syrien haben,
weil auch die Nachbarländer denen nicht richtig vertrauen.
Das sieht man ja auch, wenn Israel direkt die Gelegenheit genutzt hat,
die Waffendepots mal platt zu machen,
die quasi in dieser Umsturzzeit nicht, also als sich so zwei Tage keiner 100%
für verantwortlich fühlte, hat Syrien ja eine Menge Depots weggebombt.
Israel.
Sorry, Israel, genau, Israel in Syrien. Und mir schien aber auch,
dass das den anderen Nachbarländern wie der Türkei und so durchaus recht war,
dass alle sagen, ja, so bis wir da genau wissen, was los ist.
Wir könnten uns ja vielleicht auch als Schutzmacht anbieten, irgendwie sowas.
Ja, also es ist ja auch nicht nur Waffendepots, sondern die haben irgendwie,
glaube ich, so ziemlich alles niedergemäht.
Also die Navy haben sie, was davon noch übrig war, komplett versenkt.
Dann gab es natürlich diverse Standorte, die immer im Verdacht standen,
dort diese Chemieproduktion zu machen.
Israel hat einfach dieses Machtvakuum ausgenutzt und sich quasi mal eines Großgegners
komplett entledigt innerhalb von zwei Wochen.
Also zu den Gewinnern der Situation können wir gleich nochmal kommen,
aber das ist definitiv der Fall und an sich dürfte jetzt in Syrien,
von Syrien geht jetzt sozusagen für kein Nachbarland aktiv eine Gefahr aus.
Das eher so indirekt, weil natürlich jetzt Syrien jetzt so ein Staging-Ground
geworden ist für potenzielle Angriffe Israels, gerade weil die sich eben sozusagen
in der Luft überhaupt nicht mehr verteidigen können.
Ja genau, die Luftabwehr haben sie nämlich ganz schnell platt gemacht.
Und was ich glaube am Anfang so ein bisschen unterging für viele Leute,
Israel kann jetzt halt, könnte rein hypothetisch recht gut von Syrien über den
kurdischen Teil des Irak bis an den Iran fliegen.
Das ist eine wunderbar bequeme Route.
Und ich glaube, der Iran hat das ganz schnell geschnallt. Aber bei diesem ganzen
Trubel, den es sonst gab, ging das so in der Wahrnehmung der Welt,
schien mir ein bisschen unter dieser Aspekt.
Naja, wir hatten da, glaube ich, habe ich mit Pawel auch schon darüber gesprochen.
Genau, ihr hattet das auch, ja.
Die F-35, die kriegt halt Iran nicht detektiert.
Aber das Problem war, dass Teheran noch zu weit weg war mit der Spritversorgung.
Und jetzt, wenn sie ihre Tankflugzeuge halt über Syrien fliegen lassen können,
ist im Prinzip derzeit alles offen.
Deswegen hört man auch, ehrlich gesagt, seitdem vom Iran nicht mehr viel.
Die haben also wirklich erstmal mit sich selbst zu tun.
Und ich glaube auch, wenn die aufmucken in irgendeiner Form und nochmal versuchen,
so eine Kraftprobe da vom Stapel zu lassen, wie wir das jetzt im letzten Jahr
mit der ganzen Gaza-Situation gesehen haben, würde Israel wahrscheinlich,
ja ich weiß nicht, ob man von einem Vernichtungsschlag sprechen kann,
aber ich glaube, das hat letztes Mal schon sehr wehgetan, würde aber beim nächsten
Mal noch mehr wehtun und das wissen die glaube ich auch.
Ja, und Israel hat ja auch in diesen wenigen Tagen direkt gezeigt,
die haben schon ganz präzise Karten, wo sie hinwollen.
Das ist ja nicht, dass sie dann in dem Moment, wo sich die Gelegenheit ergab,
erstmal überlegen mussten, wo welche Chemiewaffenstützpunkte oder so sind,
sondern das ist dem Iran ja auch klar, die haben auf einem Zentimeter genau
die Karte da liegen und schon mal die Betankung berechnet.
Also ja, also so das Glück bevorzugt den, der vorbereitet ist.
Und Israel ist typischerweise sehr gut vorbereitet.
Ja, da kann man sicherlich von ausgehen, dass sie im Prinzip für jeden potenziellen
Gegenschlag schon eigentlich den Einsatzplan rumliegen haben,
den zwischendurch auch immer mal wieder aktualisieren, wenn sich neue Ergebnisse liefern.
Aber in dem Moment, wo sich die Gelegenheit bietet, geht es dann halt auch sofort
los, wie zum Beispiel eben jetzt bei diesen Schlägen auf dem syrischen Gebiet.
Da haben sie nicht erst groß drüber nachdenken müssen, sondern ich schätze mal,
die Pläne lagen da schon seit 10, 20 Jahren rum und das haben sie einfach nur
beschlossen, so okay, alles klar, jetzt gibt es da keine Luftabwehr mehr und
niemand, der in irgendeiner Form zurückschlagen kann,
jetzt hauen wir da drauf und halt auch vorher schon mit Hisbollah und so weiter, egal. Ja,
jetzt würde mich noch interessieren, es wurde ja viel gemunkelt darüber,
welche Rolle die Ukraine gegebenenfalls gespielt hat beim Start dieser Revolution.
Es wurden ja dann relativ viele Drohnen auch eingesetzt, das kennt man ja aus
dem Ukraine-Krieg und es gibt
ja eigentlich kaum ein kompetenteres Heer derzeit als das ukrainische.
Ist da was dran oder ist das nur so dahergesagt?
Also ich glaube schon, dass da ein bisschen, also schon, dass da was dran ist,
aber dass ihr Anteil nicht riesig war.
Also weil es gibt andere Gegenden, da können sie nicht mehr Ärger machen,
aber ich glaube, da haben sie gerade mehr zu tun.
Aber, so wie ich es verstanden habe, haben sie halt, wie soll man es sagen,
wie so Amtshilfe geleistet bei den Details,
die, also nicht, dass sie den großen Plan gemalt haben, aber wer auch immer
den gemalt hat, hat gesagt, ihr seid doch das Kompetenzcenter Drohnen und vor
allem Drohnen auf Russen.
Das funktioniert ja aber genauso, weil alle in der Gegend benutzen Ex-Sowjet-Technik.
Das ist ja das Angenehme.
Also so seit 50 Jahren die gleichen Panzer und Waffen im Einsatz.
Und so wie ich es verstanden habe, haben die halt so kleine,
na wie soll man es sagen, so ähnlich wie die Amerikaner das bisher gemacht haben,
wie so Berater-Teams gemacht.
Die gesagt haben, wenn du jetzt die Granate an die Drohne und so rumfliegst,
da hatten wir mal großen Erfolg mit.
Und dass das ein, also wie so ein Puzzleteil halt war.
Das funktioniert natürlich nur, wenn irgendein Staat in der Nähe,
der technisch sehr versiert ist, die ganze Aufklärung macht und halt also dieses Zusammenspiel.
Das fand ich auch ein bisschen interessant, weil also im Nahostkonflikt gibt
es Länder, die ich ein bisschen einfacher finde und ein bisschen schwieriger.
Ja, es gibt zum Beispiel Iran, da ist halbwegs klar, mit wem die gegen wen die sind, so halbwegs.
Im Irak, als der IS kam, hattest du so vier, fünf Hauptgruppen.
Und dann kommt Syrien und wenn du da mal fragst, wer kämpft eigentlich mit wem gegen wen?
In der gesamten, in den letzten irgendwie 50 Jahren, das kann dir kaum einer
erklären und oft brauchst du noch eine Zeitleiste, weil sich die Allianzen dann verschoben haben.
Oder ich meine jetzt der jetzige Präsident, der war ja bei jeder Gruppe irgendwie
mal dabei und eine andere gegründet und hier wieder raus und dann darüber.
So, und das heißt, wer überhaupt alles bei war, auf welcher Seite ist mir nicht ganz klar.
Also, dass irgendwie Israel und Ukraine und die Rebellen, die am Ende gewonnen
haben, so irgendwie im gleichen Topf gelandet sind, glaube ich, ja.
Ob die Türkei irgendwas geholfen hat, ist mir auch nicht klar,
weil die Türkei ja auch so ein bisschen Fähnlein im Wind ist und ich finde auch
ein bisschen unklar immer, was sie jetzt genau mit wem vorhaben,
aber sagen wir mal sehr opportunistisch.
Also wenn es ihnen hilft, dass erstmal irgendwie Assad weg ist,
sind sie wahrscheinlich dabei und dann sortieren sie danach,
wie jetzt ihre Allianz ist, fünf Minuten später.
Und bei den Amerikanern ist auch schwierig.
Ich glaube, deren Anteil war nicht wie sonst in der Welt, was so groß ist,
sondern geringer, weil das ist halt derzeit nicht ihr Hauptding.
Also Syrien für Amis war...
Also die hatten den Deal mit den Kurden, dass sie da ihre Ölfelder haben,
da bei DSO, aber so irgendwie halt so diese Achse, so Israel,
Ukraine und vielleicht ein bisschen Türkei, die da am gleichen Interesse gezogen haben.
Aber da bin ich auch gespannt, wie immer.
Irgendwann im Laufe der nächsten Jahre wird einer quatschen, der dabei war.
Und ich wette, da kommen noch ein, zwei Gruppen raus, die wir gar nicht auf
dem Schirm hatten oder die wir ganz woanders verortet hatten.
Auch ein Punkt ist, der Herr, der jetzt ja der Machthaber ist,
der ist ja in Riyadh geboren, aber seine Familie kommt aus Golan.
War für mich auch die Frage, hat in irgendeiner Form Saudis mitzutun gehabt?
Oder haben die da irgendein bestimmtes Interesse, was bei mir hinten rübergekippt
ist, weil ich mich mit Saudi-Arabien nicht viel befasse.
Aber gerade in der Gegend ist ja oft interessant, wer kennt wen,
wer kommt woher und wo kommt welche Familie her,
was sozusagen in deutscher Politik ja nicht so entscheidend oft ist,
aber hat sich da immer wieder rausgestellt, dass es oft so ganz strange Verbindungen
gibt, die die Insider dann sofort sehen.
Und sobald man nur ein paar Meter Abstand zu den Leuten hat, sieht man es nicht mehr.
Aber deswegen denke ich so, also das wäre grob meine Idee, aber ich wette,
in ein, zwei Jahren kommen noch irgendwelche Verstrickungen raus,
die keiner gesehen hat richtig.
Jetzt, zu den Gewinnern kommen wir gleich, aber wer die Verlierer sind, ist noch relativ klar.
Also Iran haben wir ja schon angesprochen, dadurch,
dass nach Gaza und Hamas und Hezbollah Israel sozusagen da schon so reingehauen
hat und dann auch noch Syrien wegfiel und sie dann auch noch die Angriffe geflogen haben,
ist im Iran sozusagen die komplette Achse zum Mittelmeer weggebrochen.
Sprich, es gibt jetzt keine einfache Möglichkeit mehr, in irgendeiner Form Waffen
in den Libanon zu schaffen.
Und ich denke mal, das wird dazu führen, dass die Situation im Libanon noch
lange anders ist, als sie in den letzten Jahren war.
Ich sage es mal so, wie sie genau ist. Keine Ahnung.
Und der andere große Verlierer ist natürlich Russland, wobei ich habe jetzt
mal, also Russland natürlich erstmal einerseits Verbündeter Syriens,
hat auch maßgeblich dazu beigetragen, dass sich Assad überhaupt so lange halten konnte.
Assad ist ja dann letztlich auch nach Moskau geflohen, wenig überraschend.
Es gab jetzt diese zwei Standorte, also es gab viele Standorte der Russen und
zwei große Standorte, nämlich den Flughafen, das ist ein Namen,
den ich gerade nicht aussprechen kann,
auch in der Nähe der Mittelmeerküste, in der Nähe von Latakia und dann bei Tartus halt noch den Hafen.
Da sind sie jetzt die letzten Monate, haben sie sehr viel Gerät und Kram rausgeschifft und rausgeflogen.
Auf der Live-UA-Map für Syrien ist das allerdings auch immer noch als russisch besetzt gemarkiert.
Also so ganz, so richtig komplett weg sind sie wohl noch nicht,
aber die werden doch da nicht bleiben, oder?
Also so wie ich es verstanden habe, will ja der neue Machthaber da mit allen
irgendwie okay klarkommen.
Und deswegen auch die Ansage, die Russen jetzt nicht abknallen,
wenn die fliehen oder so, sondern lasst die in Ruhe abziehen.
Egal was für einen Scheiß die gemacht haben, egal was die für Geheimnisse mitnehmen,
lass die in Ruhe gehen, dass man nicht jetzt noch jemanden gegen sich aufbringt,
wenn das alles, also es ist ja so ganz vorsichtig stabil, also alle wollen gerade
im Land oder ein signifikanter Teil im Land und im Ausland möchte gerne, dass es stabil bleibt.
Also an dieser ganz filigranen Balance jetzt nicht rütteln.
Und wenn Russland versteht, sie müssen gehen, machen das jetzt auch nach und
nach, dann ist ja das Einfachste, du lässt sie halt ganz in Ruhe gehen und machst
jetzt nicht da noch was auf.
Was da aber auch ganz interessant ist, dass Israel sich ja schon gemeldet hat
und gesagt hat, also wenn die Flugplätze dann vakant sind, also ob da schon
Nachmieter feststeht oder ob man sich da noch bewerben könnte.
Ich glaube nicht, dass das passiert aber ich finde die Denkweise immer sehr
lustig also man kann ja mal fragen.
Aber ja, ich denke die Russen werden bis auf ein Minimum abziehen und halt versuchen
irgendwie da zu feilschen, aber denen ist ja auch klar, wenn es jetzt einen
richtigen Angriff auf den Hafen oder den Flugplatz gäbe halten könnten sie das
wahrscheinlich auch nicht,
also die haben da wahrscheinlich eine Menge Waffen aber irgendwann ist die Munition
alle also würde ich von ausgehen die bleiben bis zum letzten moment und versuchen
zu verhandeln und wenn es nicht
geht müssen sie halt gehen aber die werden die werden da nicht bleiben.
Und halt auch ein Punkt wegen Verlierern bei Russland, also auf vielfältige
Ebene, aber auch dieses Renommee, dass sie einen Diktator nicht mehr schützen konnten.
Ich glaube, das ist sowas, was jetzt direkt ja nicht andere Diktatoren so beeinflusst,
aber so auf lange Sicht, mit wem will man sozusagen, wen will man als Schutz macht oder sowas.
Und da ist Russland jetzt immer noch nicht ganz schlecht, die haben ja noch
leider eine Menge Power, aber dass man sagt, aber das mit Syrien lief nicht gut.
Ja, definitiv.
Ja, kommen wir vielleicht mal so zu den Gewinnern. Also Israel haben wir ja
schon erwähnt, das ist natürlich sehr offensichtlich.
Israel ist es jetzt gelungen, über die Methoden kann man natürlich jetzt trefflich streiten,
aber sicherlich haben sie jetzt die Hamas nicht von diesem Planeten gefegt durch
ihre Angriffe, aber sicherlich nennenswert geschwächt, das gleiche mit der Hisbollah.
Aber dadurch, dass Syrien jetzt wegfällt, haben sie quasi die Zahl der aktiv
bedrohlichen Feinde auf eine geringe Zahl reduziert, sage ich mal.
Ja, und sagen wir mal auf eine Menge, die sie im Blick halten können.
Weil vorher war es ja schon schwierig.
Und ich glaube alleine, wenn man ein gutes Auge auf die Leute hat,
dann schläft man besser.
Also das könnte definitiv jetzt erstmal eine ruhigere Phase einleiten für einen
nennenswerten langen Zeitraum, weil ich meine Jordanien, weil es eh nie ein Problem,
auch Ägypten hat keinen Bock sich groß mit Israel anzulegen,
für die ist Palästina auch nur ein Problem.
Man sieht ja die Zaunhöhe nach Ägypten, also es ist jetzt ja nicht,
als würden die da visafreie Einreise nach Gaza propagieren.
Ja, ist die Zaunhöhe genauso hoch wie in Israel oder höher?
Nee, höher, wesentlich höher, so ich glaube acht Meter oder so,
die haben ja aufgestockt, wie so eine Metallwand mit mehreren Reihen,
Stacheldraht oben und drumherum.
Also da wäre Honecker stolz gewesen, wenn er irgendwo so eine Mauer gesehen hätte.
Naja, okay. Libanon befindet sich in einer permanenten Staatskrise und hat ganz andere Sorgen.
Wir brauchen ja überhaupt erstmal Strom und Essen und irgendeine Perspektive.
Und es ist auch vollkommen unklar, wie sich diese Schwäche der Hisbollah dort
politisch auswirkt, ob das irgendwelche positiven Ergebnisse haben wird.
Aber ich glaube, wenn dann nur sehr geringer Natur.
Aber so der Elefant im Raum ist natürlich die Türkei.
Die Türkei hat einerseits, ich denke mal, sie waren auf jeden Fall daran beteiligt,
diesen Zeitpunkt auch mitzubestimmen oder mindestens abzusegnen.
Und natürlich ist Erdogan auch mit Assad da ein riesen Problem losgeworden,
weil damit ist vollkommen klar,
wer die militärisch dominanten Player im Nahen Osten sind.
Das sind einfach mal Israel und die Türkei und danach kommt erstmal eine ganze
Weile lang gar nichts mehr.
Und die geopolitische Rolle der Türkei definiert sich ja ohnehin nicht nur deswegen,
sondern natürlich jetzt auch wegen Trump und der Neupositionierung der NATO ohnehin komplett neu.
Ja, und ich glaube auch wieder, Türkei, für viele in Deutschland ist die so
in den Hintergrund geraten, lange.
Also nachdem es irgendwie in den 90ern oder so ein bisschen Annäherung an die
EU gab und in den 2000ern und was viele verpasst haben, ist,
was die für eine unglaublich fette Rüstungsindustrie haben, die auch gut erprobt ist.
Zum Beispiel die Bayraktadronen, die ja in der Ukraine am Anfang so relevant
waren, die TB2, die kannte ich schon seit fünf bis zehn Jahren aus dem Irak,
weil die da immer gegen die PKK eingesetzt wurden von der Türkei.
Das heißt also auch, die sind erprobt.
Das ist halt nicht, dass man das irgendwie dreimal auf dem Hof geflogen ist,
sondern die wissen das schon.
Und auch die Kriegsschiffe, die sie haben, die sind halt modern und groß.
Und das ist auch sowas, wenn man irgendwo einen Artikel sieht,
so, ja, Türkei hat Kriegsschiffe gekauft, normalerweise schließt das nicht groß, weil es nicht spannend.
Aber die haben halt die ganzen Jahre so Stück für Stück aufgebaut und mehr gemacht.
Und jetzt stehen sie halt auf einmal an einem Punkt, wo sie diesen ganzen Kram
wirklich brauchen oder benutzen können und eben nicht in der EU hängen oder
was Ähnlichem, wo es viele Meinungen dazu gäbe oder auch nicht.
Aber ich meine, das System, wie es da ist, wenn Erdogan sagt,
baue jetzt so eine Art Panzer, dann werden die halt gebaut.
Also das ganze System ist ja auch darauf ausgelegt, in so einem Fall jetzt schnell zu reagieren.
Und alles, was so Artikel waren, die man früher nicht gelesen hat,
weil die nicht relevant waren, man sagt, hätte ich mal genauer hingeguckt.
Ich glaube, dieses ordentliche Aufrüsten und Waffenerproben von der Türkei ist
an einer Menge Leute vorbeigegangen oder noch anders.
Wenn ich hier mit Menschen spreche, die sehen das oft immer noch so,
ah, da kommt der Döner her, ja, und da kann man am Strand Urlaub machen. So, ja, schon.
Aber die sind halt echt ein Powerhouse geworden.
Und noch eine letzte Sache, die so viele vergessen haben, Und 2015 hat Erdogan
einen russischen Kampfjet abschießen lassen, der ihren Luftraum gekreuzt hat.
Der ist ein russischer Jet, der in Syrien etwas bombardiert hat und über so
eine Nupsi-Nase von der Türkei ein, zwei Sekunden geflogen ist.
Also wirklich, man sagen muss, ohne Not und ohne Gefahr.
Und auch was für eine Präzision dahinter liegt, diesen Jet in den zwei Sekunden runterzuholen.
Also richtig bösartig einfach nur. Aber einfach nur, um sich mal mit einer Weltmacht
mit Atombomben anzulegen und zu sagen, nicht in meinem Luftraum.
Und das, finde ich, ist auch sehr, sehr interessant in der ganzen Betrachtung.
So, der hat keinen Kummer mit den Amis, nicht mit den Russen.
Also, der macht halt, was er will.
Und was die anderen meinen, scheint optional.
Also, für die Nummer wird er ja in der Türkei richtig bewundert.
Also da Putin wirklich den Stinkefinger gezeigt zu haben, das war also wirklich
der Balls of Steel Award für ihn.
Und in gewisser Hinsicht, ich meine, man kann jetzt über Erdogan denken, was man möchte.
Ich habe da nicht so viele positive Gefühle generell ihm gegenüber,
schon gar nicht jetzt wegen seiner letzten Aktionen hier gegen seine politischen
Gegner. Er ist ja gerade wieder dabei, seinen größten Konkurrenten ins Gefängnis
zu schmeißen und so weiter.
Nur er ist eigentlich der einzige,
Jetzt muss man mal kurz nachdenken. Ja, das ist eigentlich der Einzige,
mal abgesehen jetzt von der Ukraine, der weiß, wie man mit den Russen umzugehen hat.
Der Einzige, den Putin komplett respektiert, ist Erdogan, weil Erdogan fackelt
nicht lange. Und Putin weiß auch, er könnte es zum Beispiel derzeit mit der
Türkei nicht aufnehmen.
Also schon gar nicht, also weder im Schwarzen Meer,
also die Ukraine hat ja sozusagen die russische Navy komplett vernichtet oder
zumindest so weit sich zurückziehen lassen, dass sie da überhaupt nichts mehr tun können.
Während eben die Türkei dort irgendwie mit 24 Fregatten und irgendwie neun Korvetten
und irgendwie 13 U-Booten und so weiter also mittlerweile eine riesige Macht darstellt.
Und vor allem halt einfach begriffen hat, wie man mit Russland umzugehen hat.
Nämlich zu sagen, einfach hier keinen Zentimeter, auch nur über unser Hoheitsgebiet,
sonst gibt es einfach sofort Ärger.
Und er hat glaube ich zwei Jahre, nach zwei Jahren hat er sich dann irgendwann mal entschuldigt.
Genau.
Dann war da wieder Ruhe. Das hat dann auch keinen mehr interessiert.
Das war dann mehr so eine Formalie mit so, okay, alles klar,
ihr dürft uns jetzt offiziell wieder lieb haben,
weil wir haben uns ja entschuldigt, aber dauert dann halt auch mal zwei Jahre
und nicht irgendwie nach zwei Wochen oder so wie es halt derzeit Europa macht mit irgendwie,
oh, da ist mal wieder was auf polnischem Gebiet runtergekommen,
eine Missa, ja, das war ja sicherlich nur aus Versehen und so weiter.
Da gibt es einfach eine Menge, was man damit schon hat.
Und kam die überhaupt aus Russland? So kam die Rakete überhaupt aus Russland?
Das war nicht die beste Diskussion.
Nee, nee, wahrscheinlich hat Portugal die im Bogen geschossen, weißt du?
Nur um uns zu ärgern. Ja, das denke ich auch. Erdogan, also sozusagen.
Erdogan heißt das so.
Erdogan.
It takes a pirate to hunt a pirate oder sowas.
Im Prinzip das Gleiche. Du brauchst halt Assis auf gleichem Niveau,
weil die können miteinander umgehen. Oder der, also da sieht man aber auch wieder,
es geht halt nicht nur um Waffen und nicht nur um sowas, sondern halt ums Auftreten.
Also ich meine, einen russischen Kampfjets abschießen, okay.
Aber rein technisch könnten eine Menge Länder das tun. Die meisten tun es halt nicht.
Und halt wirklich dieses Macho-Verhalten oder wie man es nennen will,
weiß gar nicht, wie man es nennen will.
Aber da gab es auch so einen Spruch immer aus der Türkei sinngemäß,
wenn es hieß, aber die Russen mögen das nicht oder die mögen das nicht,
dass es dann hieß, ja, aber die wählen uns ja nicht.
Also was interessiert mich die Meinung von jemandem, der nicht hier im Land
ist? Also auch dieses Grunddenken so kann ja sein, dass Putin sauer ist,
aber der ist hier nicht wahlberechtigt. Also was will der von mir?
Und ja, die sind, ich glaube, die Türkei ist auch derzeit in sechs oder sieben
Ländern im Militäreinsatz.
Also nicht so viel wie die Amis, aber zumindest die Armee ist immer wieder irgendwo,
also an Einsätzen beteiligt und eigene Sachen.
Die Rüstungsbranche ist gut, die haben Export. Also die haben so die ganze Basis,
auf der sie gut aufbauen können und die sie gut erweitern können.
Da auch so ein Punkt ist, die sind ja oft so ruhig. Ich denke,
die werden doch nicht mit ihren Fregatten da rumsitzen und nicht millimetergenau
wissen, wo die Russen sich zumindest in der Küstennähe und so bewegen.
Oder auf der Krim. Also was die wahrscheinlich jetzt schon wieder an Informationen horten.
Und so ein Verständnis zu haben, was die Russen da wie tun. Und ja,
wie du schon sagtest, also die Ukraine
quasi ohne Marine hat die russische Schwarzmeerflotte irgendwie im Griff.
Dann kann man sich aber legen, wenn die Türken nur mit einem von ihren großmodernen
Kriegsschiffen kommen und sagen so, wir fahren jetzt mal quer durch, da geht gar nichts mehr.
Also da hat die, da hat Russland dann echt nichts mehr zu lachen.
Und ich habe da eigentlich die ganze Zeit auch darauf gewartet,
ob nicht irgendwann Erdogan sagt, hey, wir machen jetzt einen Rohstoffdeal oder
irgendwas mit der Ukraine.
Also, weil es ja viel dichter dran ist. Die haben ja auch historisch echt viel
miteinander gehandelt, auch ganz viel Getreide und so, was dann über die Türkei weiterging.
Das wäre ja gar nicht so doof. Und wenn EU und NATO und alle die ganze Zeit
zwar schon der Ukraine helfen, aber ja immer so, also wie viele Politiker,
man sagen, ja, aber mit NATO-Mitgliedschaft vorsichtig und EU-Mitgliedschaft vorsichtig.
Und dann kommt ein Erdogan um die Eck und sagt, ja, ja, du, keine Ahnung,
interessiert mich nicht, wollen wir einen Deal machen oder nicht?
Also so ein bisschen wie Trump, aber schlauer sozusagen oder irgendwie ein bisschen
filigraner oder nicht so von oben herab.
Ich glaube, das ist so ein bisschen der Punkt. Aber das ist auch was,
so wie Trump halt auftritt, so tritt Erdogan nicht auf.
Das muss man ihm auch lassen. Der ist halt staatsmännisch und der schmeißt seine
politischen Gegner in den Knast.
Aber der schimpft nicht rum bei so einem Gespräch oder der ist nicht so herablassend,
wenn er was von einem will, sondern der weiß,
so wie man sich höflich verhält, wie man die Leute zu sich holt,
wenn man was von ihnen will zumindest.
Oder auch, das sieht man ja, also mit wie viel Tamtam er manchmal Gäste empfängt, wenn er was braucht.
Jaja, also der spielt das Klavier wirklich auf allen einzelnen Tasten, gar keine Frage.
Einschließlich der Fußhebel.
Ich meine, wahrscheinlich, wir reden ja jetzt, auch nachher wahrscheinlich nochmal,
generell wird ja derzeit sehr viel diskutiert über, wer würde sich gegebenenfalls
an einer Stärkung des ukrainischen Militärs mit Truppen beteiligen.
Das ist sicherlich jetzt so die Debatte, die jetzt aufzieht.
Frankreich hat sich da positioniert, ein paar andere Länder auch.
Aber wenn allein die Türkei Partei ergreifen würde und sagen würde,
das reicht uns jetzt hier.
Ja, schwarzes Meer ist auch unsere Einflusssphäre. Ihr habt jetzt hier genug,
rumgeärgert, ihr Russen. Wir fahren da mal mit unseren Schiffen mal rüber.
Ja, und belagern.
Nur gucken, nur gucken.
Also, ist jetzt ein bisschen hypothetisch, aber ich glaube, rein von der Kriegskraft
her, die von dem türkischen, von dem türkischen her, von der türkischen Navy,
von türkischen Streitkräften generell ausgeht,
könnten die Russen nicht sehr viel mehr tun, als sich schnell zurückzuziehen und das war es dann.
Also ich glaube nicht, dass sie sich gegen die Türken in irgendeiner Form wehren könnten auf der Krim.
Nur mal so klar zu machen, wie stark die sind.
Die Türkei hat ungefähr eine halbe Million aktive Soldaten, also so zweieinhalb
Mal die Bundeswehr oder so.
Und die halt viele mit zumindest so ein bisschen Erfahrung, also nicht mit Rieseneinsätzen,
aber so halt Anti-PKK-Einsatz, ein bisschen in Syrien und,
Ja, das ist eine Menge.
Die haben jetzt nicht nur Deiche gebaut in den letzten 30 Jahren.
Nee, nee, nee, nee. Und ich meine, immer wieder so kleinere Sachen,
aber wenn man jetzt mal einen Prozent guckt, wie viele von denen haben wirklich
mal eine kriegerische Auseinandersetzung gesehen?
Ich glaube, das sind ganz schön viele bei denen.
Also das macht einen entscheidenden Unterschied, denke ich auch,
wenn man das erste Mal in so eine Gegend geht oder wenn man zumindest vor zehn
Jahren Anti-IS-Einsatz oder so gemacht hat und schon mal so die Basis erlebt hat von,
was heißt das, diesen Stress zu haben und wie Logistik dann in der Praxis funktioniert und so weiter.
Deswegen, ja, und die haben halt
keine lange Anfahrt. Die haben auch Landungsboote und all so ein Kram.
Also die haben alles, es funktioniert und sie haben ein akzeptables Training da drauf.
Ich frage mich da auch immer, was Erdogan, also was ist sein Hauptinteresse,
weil eigentlich ist es die Gelegenheit doch wieder sich als starken Mann zu positionieren.
Seine Rüstungswirtschaft könnte da super noch von profitieren.
Also ich meine Bayraktar hat gut verdient schon in der Ukraine.
Sie bauen ja jetzt auch schon die neue Navy der Ukraine, also die produzierten
die ganze Zeit Schiffe für die Ukraine.
Und aber da würde ja noch mehr gehen. Und wie du sagst, der Erfolg wäre ihm relativ sicher.
Also ich sehe da auch nicht. Also erst mal immer die Sorge hiermit.
Dann kommt der Atomkrieg, wo man sagt, hey, die haben schon mal einen russischen Jet abgeschossen.
Es gab keinen Atomkrieg. Es gab gar keinen Krieg.
Touristen sind ausgeblieben das war die Folge, das war alles was Putin machen konnte.
Oder auch wenn man also man kann es ja auch ein
bisschen anders machen oder ein bisschen geschickter spielen so wie wir machen
eine humanitäre Mission und sichern halt die Getreiderouten so von Charkiv bis
Simferopol oder sowas keine Ahnung und dann sichert man halt 90% des besetzten
Territoriums und verkauft es als irgendwie einen guten Zweck Aber ja,
mich wundert es eigentlich eher, dass der da noch nicht aktiver drin ist,
weil ich dachte, das letzte Jahr schon immer,
irgendwann müsste Erdogan doch mal so aus den Löchern kommen und sagen,
so und jetzt hier, ich zeige es wieder der Welt, Türkei ist wieder eine dicke Nummer.
Und muss man ja auch sagen, die Leute da im Land mögen das ja auch zum Großteil.
Also er ist unglaublich beliebt. Ähm.
Weil er halt so ein bisschen das ist, was wie Trump sich immer verkaufen will.
Also er gilt halt schon so wie der Dealmaker oder der, der so Sachen geregelt bekommt.
Eine Sache, die seit Jahren immer wieder erzählt wird, wenn es um ihn geht,
dass Istanbul so Probleme hatte mit Wasserversorgung und Müll,
der nicht abgeholt wurde wegen Korruption.
Und dann kam er an die Macht und ich glaube nach einer Woche oder zwei war aller
Müll abgeholt und es gab nie wieder ein Problem.
Und da gibt es so verschiedene Geschichten, wie das Meeting zwischen ihm und
der Müllfirma lief, aber es war wohl eher so wie bei der Pate oder sowas,
zumindest den Überlieferungen nach, aber das ist ja dem Volk egal,
die wollten, dass der Müll abgeholt wird und der Müll wird abgeholt.
Und deswegen, wenn jetzt Merz sagen würde, geil, wir machen Krieg und wir bauen
Panzer, das würde in Deutschland ja eher so mittelmäßig gut ankommen,
je nachdem, wen man fragt.
Und wenn Erdogan sagt, komm, lass uns die mal platt machen, dann würden eine
Menge Leute sagen, ja geil, so wir sind wieder jemand, wir haben wieder was zu melden.
Und eigentlich würde ihm das, glaube ich, nur guttun politisch und wirtschaftlich am Ende.
Also ich denke, bevor er der Ukraine zum Sieg verhilft, wird er dafür sorgen,
dass Europa ihn auf Knien dazu anfleht.
Ja. Ah, stimmt, der Teil fehlt.
Weil ich denke mal, da ist für ihn noch eine Menge Leverage,
die er gerne nutzen möchte.
Der Zugang zur EU, das Fallenlassen von Visa-Pflicht,
Zugang, also ich meine, ich glaube, Mitgliedschaft in der Europäischen Union
dürfte nicht sein. Will er gar nicht.
Glaube ich.
Ja, entweder will er es nicht und wenn er es wollen würde, dann weiß er auch,
wie schwierig dieser Weg ist. Aber das ist ja nicht unbedingt das, was er braucht.
Weil so eine Partnerschaft. Wenn die Visa-Pflicht für die Türken entfallen würde,
dann wäre quasi, dafür wäre ihm das Land ewig dankbar.
Und man muss ja auch sehen, so unpopulär er bei uns sein mag,
die Türken verstehen sich schon, also zumindest jetzt sagen wir mal der Mittelbau
und vor allem natürlich Leute im Westen der Türkei,
verstehen sich einfach als Europäer und nehmen es uns, den anderen Europäern übel,
dass wir sie so an der langen Hand darstellen.
Immer wieder verhungern lassen und treiben sie ja quasi eigentlich von uns weg.
Und das zeigt sich dann eben auch an solchen Kooperationen. Das ist halt ein
riesiges Land, mehr Einwohner als Deutschland, die größte Armee in Europa.
Nur Polen wird da mittelfristig wohl mitspielen können, so wie die jetzt gerade aufrüsten.
Jetzt muss man natürlich mal schauen, was in Frankreich und England und vielleicht
auch in Deutschland noch passiert, aber da sind wir noch sehr weit von entfernt.
Also an der Türkei führt kein Weg dran vorbei.
Und am Ende muss ich zeigen, in welche Allianzen die EU und Europa jetzt bereit ist, da zu gehen.
Weil jetzt, wenn die USA nicht mehr zur Verfügung stehen, Russland zu besiegen,
muss man halt schauen, wie man die Kräfte neu ordnen kann.
Und da wird Erdogan definitiv die Hand aufhalten und ich glaube,
er hat da auch eine Menge zu gewinnen. Naja.
Nur ein Punkt noch, weil du sagst, die fühlen sich von uns immer so ein bisschen zurückgeschoben.
Was ich in der Türkei auch immer wieder gehört habe, war, okay,
wir werden kritisiert für jede Kleinigkeit.
Aber was ist mit Orban? Der darf mitspielen.
Ja.
Also man sagen muss, ja, zumindest das Argument, dass man aus deren Sicht das nicht okay findet.
Verstehe ich. Es ist ja nicht so, dass man jetzt Orban jetzt in die Europäische
Union aufnehmen würde, wenn Ungarn nicht schon drin wäre.
Nee, das nicht, aber halt.
Da bin ich auch voll bei den Türken, was das Argument betrifft.
Ich denke auch, da müsste die EU sehr viel mehr tun, Orban seine Grenzen aufzuzeigen,
aber das ist ja nochmal ein anderes Problem.
Ja, genau.
Dann lass uns doch mal aber jetzt auf die Ukraine kommen.
Ja.
Vielleicht erst mal so, wie oft warst du jetzt vor Ort seit unserer letzten
Sendung, seit Mitte Oktober, seit dem 19. Oktober?
Du warst mindestens zweimal da.
Zweimal? Ich glaube zweimal.
Ja, im Oktober war ich in Pokrovsk und danach war ich noch mal in Kramatorsk
und so, irgendwie im Januar, glaube ich.
Und jetzt war ich, ja genau, Anfang Januar und jetzt war ich halt vor ein,
zwei Wochen da und in Kherson.
Das waren, glaube ich, so die beiden Trips in der Zwischenzeit.
Und dann nächste Woche geht es wieder hin, ja.
Ja, interessiert mich natürlich, was du dort für Eindrücke gewonnen hast.
Kramatorsk ist ja quasi im Donbass der hauptmilitärische Standort,
wenn ich das richtig sehe,
was schon immer so ein bisschen das Zentrum, das Planungszentrum war für den
Einsatz der ukrainischen Armee, also auch schon vor der Fullscale Invasion.
Kherson ist die Stadt direkt am Dnipro, die quasi auf der anderen Uferseite
die Russen direkt vor der Nase hat.
Die Russen terrorisieren diese Stadt seit ihrer Befreiung am laufenden Meter,
fliegen die ganze Zeit mit Drohnen durch die Straßen und bomben Leute einfach
so ab. Ich weiß nicht, Artillerie dürfte wahrscheinlich auch regelmäßig noch einschlagen.
Wo warst du da genau? Was ist dein Eindruck von Kherson? Das würde mich immer interessieren.
Also ich war direkt in Kherson City oder wie man es nennen will.
Also es ist ja auch wieder der Oblast heißt so und die Stadt heißt so.
Und bei der Stadt ist es so, da gibt es quasi nebendran wie ein Vorort oder
so ist Anton Nifka, wo die Brücke, genau die berühmte Brücke ist, war.
Jetzt ist er irgendwie kaputt gegangen und ich war so zwei Kilometer von Antonivka,
also schon da, wo es so ein bisschen ungemütlich ist tagsüber oder auch nachts.
Ungefähr ein Kilometer vom Fluss. Und ich meine, ich kenne halt Kiew, Rakiv und so.
Und die Sachen sind, alle Städte sind ein bisschen anders. Das ist ganz interessant
in so Kriegsgebieten, auch Frontgebieten.
Zum Beispiel, es gibt Gegenden, da sind diese kleinen FPV-Drohen ein großes
Problem. Und es gibt Gegenden, da ist das nicht so ein Problem.
Und es gibt Gegenden, da ist Raketemeeren-Problem und so weiter.
Und in Kherson sind diese kleinen Drohnen ein Riesenproblem,
Weil es halt quasi Sichtverbindung ist von Seite zu Seite, wo die Kriegsparteien sind.
Und eben dazu noch Artillerie.
Und Artillerie aber vor allem nachts, weil beide Seiten fahren nachts mit der
Artillerie rum, damit man sie schlechter sieht.
Und dann schießen sie und fahren und schießen und fahren.
Und es ist halt wie so ein Katz-und-Maus-Spiel über den Fluss hinweg.
Und auf jeden Fall, die Russen treffen
meist nicht gut. Die treffen immer irgendwas, aber meist nur Häuser.
Und so einer der ersten großen Unterschiede in der Stadt war,
dass die uns gesagt haben, mach Google Maps auf deinem Handy oder auf deinem
Autonavis oder wie auch immer auf die ganze Zeit.
Mach Satellitenbild an, dass du den Fluss ordentlich siehst.
Und achte immer darauf, dass du nur parallel zum Fluss fährst.
Weil wenn du sozusagen längs, also auf den Fluss zu oder vom Fluss direkt wegfährst,
dann sehen die Russen dich gut.
Und dann haben die Zeit, auf dich zu zielen und zu schießen.
Also sozusagen nicht im Rückspiegel den Fluss haben oder vor dir den Fluss,
sondern immer nur rechts und links, wenn du über die Kreuzung fährst,
damit du möglichst wenig gesehen werden kannst.
Und so in allen anderen Gegenden, auch in Pokrovsk und so weiter,
es ist halt so, da heißt, pass auf, von oben kommt eine Drohne oder so,
aber das heißt, pass auf, die sitzen gegenüber und gucken die Straßenschlucht runter und schießen.
Das ist halt schon ein anderes Level irgendwie an Nähe und nochmal ein anderes Gefahren-Ding.
Und wenn man sich halt in der Stadt nicht auskennt, dann halt immer eine Karte
aufhaben, dass man versteht, fahre ich gerade sozusagen richtig?
Oder können die mich die Straßenschlucht runterfahren sehen,
wenn ich jetzt eine Minute lang vom Fluss wegfahre oder auf den Fluss zu?
Und es gibt im Ort, ich glaube, noch eine Ampel, die an ist,
an einer relevanten Stelle,
Sonst fahren im Prinzip alle immer
Vollgas und es gibt keine richtigen Verkehrszeichen, die beachtet werden.
Die Stadt ist aber nicht ganz leer, die ist so mittelvoll.
Das heißt, Autofahren ist wirklich auf einem völlig anderen Niveau.
Also weil man immer ganz schnell, so schnell es geht, von A nach B fährt,
halt versucht nicht direkt auf den Fluss zuzufahren und an jeder Kreuzung immer
aufpassen muss, dass man mit den anderen nicht zusammenknallt, die genauso fahren.
Und das ist überraschend anstrengend den Tag über und so eine Sache,
die man immer gar nicht so auf dem Schirm hat,
wenn man denkt, in erster Linie sind die Drohnen und die Artillerie das Problem
und dann merkt man ja plus so Alltagssachen wie eben Autofahren.
Da auch so Sachen wie Busfahrt, da fahren noch Busse, was ich total irre fand.
Da fuhr noch eine Fahrschule und hat Fahrschulausbildung gemacht.
Und die Bushaltestellen sind aber alle wie so Mini-Bunker inzwischen,
weil die ganz oft gezielt bombardiert wurden, um die Zivilbevölkerung,
die letzte, die noch da ist, rauszutreiben.
Und deswegen sind die Bushaltestellen jetzt alle wie so dreimal drei Meter Betonbunker,
also die man so am Stück vom Laster da abstellen kann einfach.
Krass ja aber auf der anderen Seite fanden da so Straßenbauarbeiten statt und die haben irgendwie,
Schlaglöcher gefixt und die haben die Grünflächen gemäht vor irgendeinem,
Verwaltungsgebäude, also die Stadtreinigung hat noch gearbeitet das finde ich
ist immer so ein komisches hin und her, also die Bäume werden gepflegt und dann
macht man Pause, weil die Drohne kommt und dann mäht man weiter.
Ja wahrscheinlich weil das einfach sehr wichtig ist, um so eine Normalität herzustellen.
Wie warst du da unterwegs? Das ist ja eher ein beschränkter Bereich.
Also ich dürfte da jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht hinfahren.
Nein, dich hätte ich an der Tankstelle draußen abgesetzt.
Die sind da ja gut ausgestattet, kannst du zwei Tage durchhalten.
Nee, ich habe eine Genehmigung bekommen vom Militär vor Ort,
dass ich halt für Konfliktforschung reinfahren darf und mir das angucken darf.
Und das ist so, das ist ganz interessant. Das ist ein bisschen anders als so
eine normale Pressefreigabe.
Also ich meine, Pressefreiheit ist ja eh relativ in den akuten Kriegsgebeten.
Da gibt es so Militärakkreditierungen, die klare Deals haben.
Und wenn ich da mit meiner Genehmigung reinfahre, ist so, ich darf hin,
ich darf alles angucken, ich kann halbwegs alles filmen, außer jemand sagt, das bitte nicht.
Also da ist es nicht ganz eindeutig geregelt.
Aber ich darf halt nicht im Detail jetzt drüber berichten, sondern das ist so sinngemäß.
Ich darf Informationen horten und so wie wir hier so allgemein drüber sprechen,
aber ich dürfte jetzt keine Details über was da genau ist oder irgendwas erklären.
Was ja auch für die meisten Leute jetzt gerade gar nicht so relevant ist.
Also ob die Artillerie von rechts nach links oder links nach rechts gefahren
ist, ist ja halbwegs egal.
Sondern es geht darum, dass ich halt die Möglichkeit habe, dieses Geschehen
jetzt zu erfassen und zu dokumentieren und zu einem späteren Zeitpunkt,
wenn es für die Leute dort sicher ist, benutzen kann.
Und da gibt es ganz viele so Kleinigkeiten. Zum Beispiel ist eine relevante
Information, wo man noch einen Supermarkt hat oder wo noch ein Café oder ein Restaurant auf hat.
Was ja unter normalen Umständen in anderen Städten total unkompliziert ist.
Und in so Gegenden gibt es dann ein paar, die noch aufhaben,
die aber von außen nicht erkennbar sind.
Und da hatten sie so Probleme, dass zum Beispiel ein paar Journalisten,
die sie noch reingelassen haben, dann tolle Porträts gemacht haben,
wie irgendwie jemand in einem bestimmten Café den tollsten Kaffee serviert.
Und dann kann man sich halt vorstellen, die Russen lesen auch Zeitungen und
sagen, ach, in dem Café seid ihr alle.
Gut zu wissen. Und das sind so sozusagen die Details, die man dann außen vor
lassen muss, was dann so Teil des Deals ist, was ja aber auch für mich nicht schlimm ist.
Das ist ja ein Deal, den ich ganz unkompliziert mitnehmen kann.
Und was da noch interessant ist, man hatte relativ früh eine Ausgangssperre.
Ich glaube, um 20 Uhr hat die angefangen, 19 oder 20 Uhr und dann bis 6 Uhr
morgens ungefähr. Das ist für die Ukraine schon ganz schön viel.
Und ich hatte mich gewundert, weil meine Erfahrung ist sonst,
dass es dicht an der Front quasi keine mehr gibt, die beachtet wird oder eine sehr späte.
Und wir haben gesagt, da geht es vor allem darum, dass die halt alles mögliche
Militärgeräte hin und her bewegen.
Und je weniger Augen das sehen, weil man am Ende keinem vertraut, desto besser.
Also es geht gar nicht darum, wie früher in Kiew, dass nichts geplündert wird
oder sowas in der Art, sondern halt, dass möglichst wenig Augen sehen,
was sich so nachts im Schatten tut.
Ja, und wenn die Verkehrssituation auch so problematisch ist,
dass da alle so rumballern, dann will man natürlich auch nicht die ganze Zeit
in irgendwelche Panzer reinfahren, die ja irgendwie durch die Straßen ziehen.
Wir mussten auch einmal nachts fahren. Also ich bin gefahren worden.
Ich bin da nicht selber gefahren, weil das echt wild ist.
Und die sind halt mit, also teilweise ohne Licht und teilweise mit Standlicht
mit dem Auto gefahren, sodass man sich nur gegenseitig sieht.
Weil wie die Straße verläuft, wissen sie ja. Das ist dann so ein bisschen wie
so Magic Mountain Achterbahn im Dunkeln.
Also die so drei von vier im Auto wissen, wo es lang geht, ich nicht.
Und dann fahren die da halt sehr schnell die Straße runter und sagen,
oh, da reflektiert was, da ist ein Auto, okay.
Also mir schien, das ist wirklich das Gefährlichste. Aber ja,
wenn man dann so einen Panzer oder so fährt, wäre blöd.
Was war die, hast du mit Leuten vor Ort sprechen können?
Ich höre von Chesson halt immer wieder, dass es, naja,
obwohl sie natürlich sehr glücklich waren, dass sie von der unmittelbaren russischen
Besatzung befreit wurden, ist das natürlich jetzt so eine Situation,
ist ja die einzige Großstadt, die quasi unmittelbar auch die Front ist.
Das ist ja kein Zustand, in dem man mental problemlos bestehen kann.
Nein, das ist wirklich, also nur so das Level, wie wir das ist.
Wir wollten an einer Stelle parken und an dem Parkplatz stand so ein Schild
hier, nicht parken, Achtung, Clustermunition.
Und dann aber ein so ein Clustermunitions drin drangenagelt,
so sieht das aus. Darauf musst du achten.
Also so für den Fall, dass du da parken willst und noch nicht weißt,
was Cluster Munition ist, sogar noch ein Sample.
Pass auf, dass du hier nicht drauf trittst und lauf außenrum,
aber das Gebäude dahinter hat schon auf. Es ist nur nicht geräumt.
Und ja, also das ist kein Zustand. Das ist nicht wie Kiew oder selbst Trakiv,
was ja zwar angegriffen wird, aber wo ziemlich normales Leben herrscht.
Das ist auch so. Ich habe da mit ein paar Leuten gesprochen.
Es ist so das Übliche. Da sind halt noch Leute von Polizei, Rettungsdienst,
alte Leute, die einfach nicht gehen wollen.
Das Abgefahrenste, mit dem ich gesprochen habe, das waren Ukrainer von einer
NGO, die das Sozialtaxi vor Ort betreiben, wo ich gedacht habe,
was meinst du? Also sagt er na so, wenn Rollstuhlfahrer irgendwie hin und her
gefahren werden müssen oder so, das machen sie.
Und die haben halt so ein, na so ein, wie so ein Transporter mit so einem Rollstuhllift.
Und wenn dann zum Beispiel jemand zum Arzt muss, wird der gefahren.
Sagt, Moment, in Rerson derzeit.
Sagen ja, so alte Leute, die nicht wegziehen wollen, die brauchen ja Mobilität
und die haben Anspruch drauf.
Also sind das junge Freiwillige, also jünger als 30 Jahre alt,
die damit ungepanzerten, wie so, ich glaube, hier wäre das so Telebus oder so
rumfahren und die Leute zu ihren Terminen fahren, während Drohnen in der Luft
sind, während Artillerie fliegt.
Aber es ist alles, also da ist halt kein normales Leben. Es ist halt auch kein Zustand.
Und die allermeisten Leute sind halt auch weg. Also sie sind befreit, ja, das ist gut.
Oder wenn du auch, ich habe in Kiew mit Leuten gesprochen, die aus Reherson
kamen, die sagen, hey, das ist prima, dass es befreit ist.
Weil zumindest ist es jetzt nicht unter russischer Besatzung.
Aber ich kann da halt nicht wohnen.
Also es sind ja noch zwei sehr verschiedene Fragen.
Ja, klar.
So, jetzt haben wir natürlich neue Situationen. Spätestens seit dem Ereignis
im Oval Office dürfte allen klar sein,
dass Trump überhaupt gar kein Interesse an irgendeiner geordneten Außenpolitik hat.
Und während halt seine Leute vor allem innenpolitisch anfangen,
irgendwie die USA in so ein kleines Russland umzubauen,
bleibt quasi die Außenpolitik ja komplett auf der Strecke.
Hat sich jetzt mittlerweile auch in Europa rumgesprochen?
Ich glaube, wir sind uns da sehr einig in der Bewertung,
die man so mit, haben wir euch seit drei Jahren gesagt, zusammenfassen kann.
Ja.
Jetzt wachen halt so einige auf. Ich weiß noch nicht, wie umfangreich diese
Erweckung ist, aber zumindest ist ja sehr viel Bewegung in die Geschichte gekommen.
Mich würde jetzt mal interessieren, was du mitbekommen hast,
wie die Ukrainer das sehen.
Weil das dürfte ja auf der einen Seite,
ich vermute mal, es ist eine Mischung aus einem Schock,
der vielleicht nicht so, weil es unerwartet war, sondern eher wie schnell und
wie brutal es stattgefunden hat.
Auf der anderen Seite kann ich mir auch vorstellen, dass das durch so eine gewisse
Resilienz konterkariert wird. Was hast du da wahrgenommen?
Also wirklich tatsächlich das allererste, was ich an dem Abend dazu gesehen habe, war ein Meme.
Und zwar gibt es so ein Meme von, ich glaube aus dem Film Fluch der Karibik.
Da hängen zwei Leute am Galgen und sollen gleich gehangen werden.
Und der eine sagt zum anderen First Time und sagt, ach komm,
da kommen wir wieder raus.
So, und dieses Meme, und da sagt ein Kurde zum Ukrainer, first time,
weil die Kurden sagen, hey, dass die Amis dich hängen lassen,
ja, kennen wir, kennen wir, seid nicht so überrascht.
Ja, ja.
Ja, und da habe ich gesagt, stimmt, stimmt, das vergisst man immer wieder,
aber so in Kurdistan, Irak mit, Leute, lehnt euch auf und wir helfen euch gegen Saddam in den 90ern.
Und dann gesagt, ah, doch nicht, wir haben einen guten Deal mit Saddam,
habt viel Glück mit dem, ne, tschüss.
Deswegen, ja, das dachte ich auch, das hat man auch nicht mehr so auf dem Schirm.
Aber bei den Ukrainern war bei ganz vielen so, dass sie gesagt haben,
hey, danke für alles, was ihr gemacht habt, also an die USA und danke,
dass ihr weitermacht, weil allen klar ist,
mit Trump musst du ultra vorsichtig sein und wenn jetzt alle artig sagen,
danke, danke, danke, dann ist das das Einzige, was dir überhaupt helfen kann.
Also so, wenn überhaupt, dann ihm so lange Honig ums Maul schmieren,
bis er sich wieder freut.
Auch als der NATO-Chef jetzt vor ein paar Tagen bei Trump war,
der hat ja auch gesagt, toll und danke und super, wie du das hier,
wie du diesen Stillstand in den Russland-Ukraine-Verhandlungen wieder in Bewegung gekriegt hast.
Wo ich auch dachte, gut, das muss man ja ihm ja auch nicht, sozusagen,
der wird gesagt haben, was er sagen muss, damit es gut läuft.
Klar, alles okay, verstehe ich. Der versucht halt irgendwie die Sache am Laufen zu halten.
Aber natürlich, also mehrere Sachen. Zum einen sagen ganz viele Ukrainer mir
inzwischen, hätten wir die Atombomben mal nie abgegeben.
Also 1994 das einzige Land, was je freiwillig Atombomben aufgegeben hat.
Drittstärkste Atommacht der Welt, USA, Russland, Ukraine.
Und die haben sie ja freiwillig abgegeben gegen Sicherheitsgarantien unter anderem
von den USA und sagen also sorry, aber fuck, hätten wir die Dinger mal nie abgegeben,
dann hätten wir jetzt diesen Krieg nicht und vielleicht hätten wir dann in Zukunft
irgendwann gerne wieder Atombomben, um das zu verhindern.
Das finde ich ist so eine langfristig halt sehr bedenkliche Entwicklung,
dass auf einmal wieder mehr Leute Atombomben wollen, weil sie sehen,
wie die relevant sein können.
Polen ist ja auch schon in der Diskussion.
Genau. Leute, ich meine, Polen und die baltischen Staaten sind auch jetzt auch
aus der Ottawa-Convention ausgetreten, zumindest erstmal wegen Landminen und solchen Sachen.
Und Cluster-Munität.
Genau, Cluster, die beiden waren es. Und das ist auch, wo ich denke, ich verstehe das total.
Aber es ist halt eine nette Entwicklung. Es ging auch nicht um Landminen,
sondern um Antipersonenminen, glaube ich.
Ja, genau, Panzerminen waren ja zulässig, aber genau, dass sie in die russisch
gerichtete Grenze, sei es Belarus oder was auch immer, Antipersonenminen vergraben dürfen.
Es ist halt richtig ekliges Zeug. Gibt es einen Grund, warum es die Konvention
gibt, aber ja, die sehen ja in der Ukraine, wie man, also eigentlich zwei Sachen.
Bei der Ukraine zum einen sagen sie halt, okay, das ist richtig übel und die
sind auch richtig sauer, weil es ist ja auch nicht, dass man sich gesittet irgendwie
voneinander getrennt hat oder so.
Es war ja wirklich dieses total von oben herab auf quasi die ganze Ukraine scheißen
und denen sagen, wie blöd sie sind, klar, das.
Kommt nie gut an.
Und der andere Punkt, den ich so zumindest aus Europa, also hattet ihr ja auch
ausführlich in der letzten Sendung, hatte es, warum sind uns die Amis eigentlich so wichtig?
Das ist unser Hinterhof und wir kriegen es nicht gebacken. Also ganz grob gesagt,
also hier die EU, wenn man jetzt noch Türkei dazu nimmt, weil die ja ein praktischer
Partner wären und Ukraine,
da hast du dann irgendwie, ich glaube so 400 Millionen Leute oder so mit zusammen
sehr viel Armee und wir brauchen die Amis,
um uns gegen irgendwie 160 Millionen Russen zu verteidigen, mal jetzt ganz plump
auf ein paar Zahlen runtergebrochen.
Warum brauchen wir deren Hilfe? Okay, weil wir uns Jahrzehnte nicht um sowas gekümmert haben.
Aber das ist halt das andere Problem. Und ja, was ich aus der Ukraine mitbekomme,
ist halt, dass sie ganz viel sagen, okay, also an dem Abend,
ich habe von Freunden, also die waren offensichtlich ziemlich besoffen,
weil sie sich richtig vollgekippt haben an dem Abend und sagten, das war's jetzt.
Die haben aber auch richtig düstere Nachrichten geschickt mit so,
ja, okay, das war's, dann sterben wir halt bald. und hier geht nichts mehr und so.
Ich dachte, okay, aber das hat halt gezeigt, wie die Stimmung bei einigen war.
Und die haben am nächsten Tag gesagt, oh Gott, ignoriere mich.
Das war kein guter Abend. Dann sagt, ja, ja, aber da wird ja die Wahrheit und
die Gedanken mitgeschwungen haben bei dem, was du geschrieben hast.
Also es ist jetzt nicht so, dass die es in dem Moment nicht gedacht haben.
Und das war halt, wie es bei vielen ankam, so dass das war es.
So die Sache ist durch.
Und zum anderen dann auch, wofür haben wir denn dann jetzt überhaupt gekämpft?
Dann hätte man doch direkt am Anfang sagen können, zack, das war's,
drei Tage Krieg, alles russisch, weil wenn die es jetzt eh kriegen sollen oder
das so das Ergebnis wäre.
Das hat sich zum Glück inzwischen wieder so ein bisschen beruhigt.
Aber eben, dass ja allen klar ist, die USA sind leider kein zuverlässiger Partner mehr.
Also auch wenn sie jetzt wieder helfen und hin und her, aber jetzt ist ja allen
klar, das ist jetzt Glückssache, wie lange die noch wem wo helfen oder wann
sie sich wieder rausziehen.
Und das ist ja, das war auch, ich habe gestern mit so 20 Studenten über andere
Themen gesprochen, das nur am Rande.
Und die sind halt alle so Anfang 20, also so 2000 oder später geboren.
Also sie sind geboren, als ich meinen Führerschein hatte.
Das ist schon schlimm genug. Ich bin alt geworden, habe ich gemerkt. So, und dann...
Den irgendwie, dass die USA so diese Schutzmacht Europas so ist und was das
zerrüttet gerade, also wie unglaublich dieser Moment ist,
das ging an den meisten von denen völlig vorbei, weil denen das gar nichts sozusagen
gesagt hat oder was das jetzt,
also was die Folgen sind.
Also wie hier gerade durch Europa so eine Welle geht mit, oh Mist,
wir müssen uns jetzt um unsere eigene Sicherheit kümmern und dass wir reden
von fünf bis zehn Jahren, die das jetzt ändert in gesamten Staatsplanung der gesamten EU.
Da habe ich gemerkt, denen ist das überhaupt nicht, die wussten nicht,
wovon ich rede, hatte ich das Gefühl, ganz böse gesagt.
Und das fand ich halt auch strange, weil alle Leute in meinem Umfeld,
denen war in dem Moment oder an dem Abend klar so, okay, jetzt verschiebt sich gerade die Welt,
und dann merke ich so, es gibt andere Leute, die kennen diese Verbindung gar
nicht, um es mal so zu sagen, was ich mir kaum vorstellen konnte.
Also das fand ich auch sehr... Leute in der Ukraine oder Leute in...
In Deutschland, genau, also die immer hier im sicheren Land gelebt haben,
für die es nichts anderes gibt und Und ja, dann hat Trump da halt irgendeinen Typen angemeckert.
So ist Trump halt. Aber was hat das mit mir zu tun?
Und in Polen, die scheinen sehr klar zu verstehen, was das mit ihnen zu tun hat.
Ja, ja, ich denke, das ist kurz hinter der Grenze Deutschlands.
Ja, ja, da geht das dann los. Innerhalb von Deutschland ist es wirklich absurd teilweise.
Aber ich glaube, die Realität wird sich jetzt auch langsam einstellen.
Hast du was gehört, wie die Ukrainer diese Rolle von Zelenskyj in dem Moment
in der Situation bewerten?
Man hätte ja einfach die ganze Zeit den Stiefel lecken können,
Hauptsache wir behalten unsere Unterstützung oder ich hatte eher den Eindruck, es lief andersrum.
Ja genau, ich hatte also zwei Sachen, zum einen was man bedenken muss, Selensky,
spricht nicht so gut Englisch, der kann zwar schon das ist okay,
das hat sich auch in den letzten drei Jahren verbessert, aber der ist auf keinen
Fall flüssig, also der braucht bei Englisch immer noch Dolmetscher,
und wenn man einfache Interviews mit ihm macht oder wenn man so mal salopp gesagt
Smalltalk mit ihm macht, das geht aber wenn es in komplexe Dinge geht oder auch
bei Redewendungen oder sowas, da merkt man einfach,
die Sprache, er spricht die nicht so lang, die war früher für sein Leben nicht so relevant.
Und ich glaube, das ist ein so ein Punkt.
Dass, dass ich mir halt nicht sicher bin, wie exakt er allen Details des Gesprächs
folgen konnte. Also im Groben schon.
Aber es kann halt, ich meine, wenn es um Politik geht und um Staatschefs,
da sind ja auch so Nuancen und Details wichtig.
Und ich vermute, dass das zumindest nicht, nicht nahtlos alles geklappt hat.
Das aber nur so als ein Aspekt, den man im Kopf haben muss.
Das andere war, was ich viel von Ukrainern gehört habe, dass die gesagt haben,
der hat das schon richtig gemacht, weil er hat sich ja sehr höflich bedankt die ganze Zeit.
Und selbst als er angemeckert wurde, hat er gesagt, nee, ich habe euch immer
gedankt und das war gut, was ihr gemacht habt.
Es ist ja nicht, dass Zelensky da irgendwie auf Krawall gebürstet war da so,
sondern er war wirklich sehr, sehr lange sehr, sehr höflich und eigentlich bis zum Ende.
Er ist ja nie richtig patzig geworden. Er hat nur irgendwann gesagt,
Leute, aber extrem defensiv die ganze Zeit.
Und was ich von den Ukrainern gehört habe, ist, dass sie gesagt haben,
der hat das sehr gut gemacht, weil sie wären schon lange an die Decke gegangen.
Also er war sehr viel Staatsmanager.
Also umgekehrt, du warst ja auch in der Ukraine. Stell dir mal vor,
du hättest, so wie Trump mit Zelensky gesprochen hat, mit unserem Barkeeper da gesprochen.
Also da wäre das Gespräch kurz gewesen mit einem durchschnittlichen Ukrainer.
Deswegen sagen die, der hatte sich schon gut im Griff.
Das ist alles okay. Okay, aber das andere ist ja auch, ganz offensichtlich wollte
man ja diesen Konflikt auf US-Seite.
Also, dass dieser Journalist, der ja nicht meiner ist, die Frage so gestellt
hat und Vance und so, das war ja, offensichtlich war da irgendwie ein Plan hinter.
Selbst wenn Selenskyj dieses Mal auf Biegen und Brechen das irgendwie noch gewuppt
hätte, wie auch immer, dann wäre es ja beim nächsten Mal eskaliert oder irgendwas.
Aber es war ja klar, da soll es hingehen.
Oder umgekehrt, er hatte ja überhaupt keinen Anteil an dieser Eskalation.
Also es ist ja nicht, dass es sich aus Versehen irgendwie, dass man aneinander vorbeigeredet hat.
Und zum Beispiel mit Macron, als der ja ein paar Tage oder so vorher da war,
der hat ja auch Trump verbessert und gesagt, warte mal, warte mal,
auf eine charmante und höfliche Art, nur da ist ja gar nichts eskaliert.
Da hätte Trump ja genauso hochgehen können oder so und sagen können,
red mir hier nicht dazwischen und ich weiß das besser, sondern da sah man ja ganz klar,
das war so gedacht, also konnte Zelensky da nichts mehr am Ausgang ändern und
dafür hat er sich extrem gut gegeben,
zum einen sehr defensiv, sehr höflich und was sie aber sagten,
aber trotzdem schon immer klar mit Positionen Ukraine im Kopf.
Also er hat ja schon eben nicht den Stiefel lecker gemacht, er hat gesagt,
ich danke euch, aber wir brauchen trotzdem diese Hilfe.
Und das, was ich allgemein von den Ukrainern gehört habe, war,
dass er es positiv macht.
Ja, und das ist halt nichts, am Ende war er halt eine Statistenrolle in einem Spiel einfach.
Ja, mit Umfragen ist das immer so eine Sache, aber es wurde ja dann relativ
schnell deutlich, dass das seinem Ansehen eher förderlich war.
Ich meine, er ist ja jetzt auch nicht komplett unumstritten in der Ukraine,
wie sollte das auch anders sein? Aber seine Zustimmungswerte sind dann eher
deutlich hochgegangen.
Mit anderen Worten, man hat sich da schon solidarisiert.
Aber mal weg von dieser konkreten Situation.
Was denkst du, wie jetzt die Grundhaltung ist und hat die Ukraine noch Vertrauen in Europa?
Ich glaube, das ist jetzt bescheinend.
Ich meine, mäßig. Ich glaube, so mittel. Aber es war ja auch nie anders.
Also, was bei diesen Diskussionen ja immer wieder rauskommt,
ist, der Krieg in der Ukraine ging los. Und Deutschland sagt, wir helfen sofort.
Wir schicken 5000 Helme.
Genau, das war so.
Das war echt wie aus so einem Monty-Python-Sketch. Wir müssen handeln.
Wir müssen handeln. Wir machen eine Diskussion.
Was, wenn wir euch mit einer Banane angreifen?
Genau. Und dann haben die ja noch Monate gebraucht. Ich glaube,
die haben vier, fünf Monate gebraucht, bis sie wirklich da waren und so.
Es war halt nur peinlich.
Und das ist aber so symbolisch, finde ich.
Oder dann auch, als es um die Abstimmung ging, als die Ukraine gesagt hat,
sie können Taurus gerade echt dringend brauchen. Also es ist auch ein bisschen hin und her.
Und als es dann hieß, nee, stimmen wir gegen.
Und dann aber Leute sagen, ich wäre voll dafür gewesen, ich habe aber dagegen
gestimmt, weil halt sachpolitische Zwänge. Und sagt, okay, dann wissen wir ja,
wo bei dir die Prioritäten liegen,
nämlich bei sachpolitischen Zwängen und nicht, was der Ukraine hilft.
Und auch solche Sachen. Und auch jetzt, wenn ich diese Diskussion mir immer
wieder irgendwie angucke, es geht nicht darum, wie können wir denen helfen oder
wie können wir am Ende den Konflikt lösen, wie auch immer.
Mir ist ja jeder Weg recht, der am Ende zum Ergebnis führt.
Sondern es heißt dauernd, ja, aber der hat den Antrag gestellt und das ist doof.
Also immer dieses Kleingestreit, man sagt, solange die das nicht auf die Kette
kriegen, mal irgendwie wirklich Fokus auf das Problem, sehe ich da nicht viel.
Und bei den Ukrainern auch so, die sagen, hey, ihr habt da so 20,
30 Länder, die immer diskutieren.
Und dann irgendwie wird mal geholfen, dann ist eine andere Regierung,
dann gibt es hier wieder eine Abstimmung.
Aber nicht, dass man sagt, da kann man solide mit planen oder kann man Krieg
mit planen. Vielen Dank.
Sondern mal kommt was, dann kommt nichts, dann ist wieder anders.
Und so funktioniert halt ganz salopp gesagt Militärlogistik nicht.
Wenn du sagst, ich brauche meine Artilleriegranaten, dann heißt es,
okay, wir machen mal in zwei Monaten mit vier Ländern eine Diskussionsrunde, ob wir helfen können.
Und also nicht, dass sie sich komplett im Stich gelassen fühlen,
aber dass sie halt so sagen, ihr habt immer noch nicht verstanden, was los ist.
Also ihr habt immer noch nicht kapiert, was das mit euch zu tun hat.
Sondern es ist immer noch so ein Abstand für alle außer Polen.
Auch bei Polen ist ja so, direkt zu Kriegsbeginn haben die so unglaublich geholfen.
Und ich habe es ja auch gemerkt, wenn wir Sachen über die Grenze bringen mussten
oder wenn wir irgendwas in Polen
zu tun hatten zu der Zeit, wenn wir Hilfe leisten wollten in der Ukraine.
Die ganzen Behörden haben gesagt, stell dich vorne an, fahr an der Schlange
vorbei, können wir euch tragen helfen? Also alles.
Und das ist halt auch alles deutlich zurückgegangen. Also weil Polen,
man sieht ja, dass sie die Gefahr aus Russland ernst nehmen,
aber sie sehen auch, dass die Ukraine ihren Teil derzeit ganz gut hinbekommt, so als Puffer.
Und da merkt man, selbst in Polen ist sozusagen die Unterstützung Versetzungen
direkt zur Ukraine, na so zurückgerollt oder so.
Also nicht mehr diese Panik. Russland könnte gleich bei uns vor der Tür stehen,
sondern nur die Ukraine können verlieren. Aber Polen ist noch ein paar Jahre sicher.
Und je weiter weg, desto schlimmer wird es halt.
Und ja, die fühlen sich jetzt nicht komplett verlassen, aber halt auch nicht
voll ernst genommen, sondern so eins von vielen Themen.
Ja, dem ist sicherlich auch so.
Ja.
So, jetzt haben wir ja demnächst eine neue, ich weiß nicht, ob das Wort neu
überhaupt so ein gutes Wort ist, aber eine andere Regierung.
Neuer Wein in alten Schläuchen.
Genau.
In Deutschland. Jetzt war ja bisher die Rolle Deutschlands eher so naja,
also von 5000 Helmen zu Taurus ja vielleicht, mal gucken, rufen nächste Woche nochmal an.
So, jetzt haben wir ja natürlich Friedrich Merz, den unerfahrensten Politiker,
der je Bundeskanzler geworden ist.
Der steht jetzt hier irgendwie Ante Portas, beginnt jetzt irgendwie seine Regierungszeit
erstmal mit dem kompletten Gegenteil von dem, was er angekündigt hat.
Schuldenbremse und so weiter. Ich meine, es war politischen Beobachtern,
glaube ich, eh schon immer klar, dass das sozusagen sofort umfallen wird.
Das ist halt trotzdem interessant und man muss halt mal sehen,
was außer weniger Steuern für reiche Leute irgendwie noch übrig bleibt von seinen Forderungen.
Aber er hat sich ja extrem festgelegt, was so Details wie Taurus,
Lieferungen und so weiter betrifft.
Und jetzt ist natürlich das beschlossene Sondervermögen oder wie auch immer
das heißt, also die Neuverschuldung sozusagen.
Schulden am Ende, ja.
Das ist ja jetzt durch und jetzt muss er im Prinzip auch reagiert werden.
Hast du irgendeine Erwartungshaltung, was jetzt passieren wird,
vor allem ob Deutschland noch irgendeine Rolle in Europa bereit ist zu übernehmen?
Man sieht ja jetzt der politische Gewinner der aktuellen Situation,
ich finde das Wort Gewinner ein bisschen schwierig, lass es mich anders formulieren,
die auffallendste Kraft, sagen wir mal in der gesamteuropäischen,
politischen Diskussion ist ganz klar Frankreich mit Macron die natürlich gut
dastehen weil sie sagen können, haben wir schon immer gesagt so hier Abhängigkeit
von Amerikanern eine ganz schlechte Idee.
Guck mal, wir sind jetzt die einzigen, die noch Waffen haben,
die irgendwie nicht von Amis abgeschaltet werden können.
Plus einer weitergeführten Debatte, um in irgendeiner Form mit Troops on the Ground,
da voranzukommen. Also, wie denkst du, wird sich das mit Deutschland,
England und Frankreich konkret entwickeln?
Weil ich denke, wenn sich da
nichts entwickelt, brauchen wir über den Rest gar nichts zu diskutieren.
Ja, zum einen, das mit den französischen Waffen hatte Pavel ja auch schon,
glaube ich, letztes Mal relativ viel zu gesagt.
Also, das dachte ich auch genau das.
Jahrelang sind die sozusagen belächelt worden, weil es das ist wie so der eine
Datenschutz-Nerd, den man kennt, der kein Android benutzt und kein iPhone und
immer seinen Scheiß frickelt. und sagt, voll geil, ist totaler Mist.
Und so ein bisschen, finde ich, ist das mit Frankreich. So, ja,
ja, macht mal schön eure Buchäckern sammeln da drüben.
Und jetzt können sie sagen, haben wir euch immer gesagt. Haben wir immer gewusst,
waren wir immer richtig. Und gönne ich ihnen.
Ja, und ich glaube, ein großes Problem ist halt, durch Brexit damals auch,
die Briten und Franzosen sind halt so die Armeen, die wirklich kriegserfahren noch sind.
Und die funktionieren, die die Routine haben. Also Briten ja noch mal mehr.
Aber die Franzosen, das geht auch immer so an Leuten vorbei,
fast überall, wo Amis und Briten waren, waren auch die Franzosen mit irgendwie unterwegs.
Auch französische Spezialeinheiten in Syrien die letzten Jahre,
so in den kurdischen Gebieten, was auch so immer so ein bisschen untergeht.
Das heißt, die sind ganz fit und ich glaube, das ist einer von zwei Punkten
klar, dass sie halt auf ihre eigene Rüstung gesetzt haben, aber eben auch dass
sie einfach wissen, wie man Krieg macht deutlich mehr als die Bundeswehr.
Und dass sie halt mit NATO und EU die haben ja schon genug mit Amerikanern zu tun, aber eben,
immer mit so einem kritischen Blick drauf oder immer so ein bisschen Also doch
deutlich anders als, sagen wir mal, das deutsch-amerikanische Verhältnis,
was ja immer auch viel von Vorschusslorbeeren, egal was passiert, geprägt ist.
Deswegen denke ich, wenn es jetzt um Truppen oder um Aufrüsten oder irgendwas
geht, da ist es wirklich nicht für Europa, aber für die EU sehr schlecht,
dass die Briten raus sind.
Weil die waren, was das angeht, wirklich relevant.
Und ja, also für uns und auch wiederum für den Kontakt zu den Amis,
weil das ja auch besser ist.
Deswegen, ja, Macron, ich glaube, der kann sich nichts Besseres vorstellen derzeit
als seine Rolle auf einmal, dass sie auch so Aufgaben übernehmen.
Die haben ja auch sofort geholfen, ein bisschen bei der nachrichtendienstlichen
Sache, dass sie den Ukrainern geholfen haben.
Mit Aufklärungsflügen über dem Schwarzen Meer. Die Italiener aber auch.
Die Italiener sind ja mit ihren, diese kleinen Airwags, die so groß sind wie
so ein Privatjet von, ich glaube, Saab oder was die da benutzen.
Auf jeden Fall, die sind nun mal kleiner.
Die sind auch sofort wieder über das Schwarze Meer geflogen.
Und da habe ich gesagt, warum schicken wir nicht unseren Airwags?
Weil wir keinen haben. Okay, da geht die Story doch schon wieder los.
Wir dürfen halt diesen NATO-RX mit benutzen, aber wir haben,
glaube ich, gar nichts in der Größenordnung mehr richtig.
Und ja, jetzt.
Das ist so ein bisschen blöd, weil eigentlich ist es im Team ja immer besser,
also sei es EU, sei es ein Verteidigungsbündnis und so weiter,
aber wenn sich im, also eigentlich wie früher in der Schule,
wenn man so eine Gruppenarbeit macht und alle haben sich immer darauf verlassen,
dass der eine es richtig macht und der stellt sich dann als Assi raus und macht nicht mehr mit.
Und auf einmal haben wir ein Problem mit der NATO, wenn die Amis halt nicht
mehr sich um alles kümmern.
Das Traurige finde ich nur, bei der Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz seit den 60er
Jahren sagt jeder Ami-Präsident oder Vertreter, der da auftritt,
ihr müsst euch mehr um eure Sicherheit kümmern.
Und alle sagen immer, haha, guter Gag, ja, nächstes Jahr wieder.
Aber die haben das seit 60 Jahren gesagt, ne?
Alle Verteidigungsexperten haben das gesagt und immer wenn es dann dazu kommt,
heißt ja, aber so Waffen kaufen kostet halt nur Geld und ist unbeliebt also
das finde ich auch so komisch in Deutschland,
zum einen ist es ja ganz gut, dass wir nicht so wirklich so diese Waffenfans
und Waffenfetischisten so hier haben, aber,
es kippt halt regelmäßig dann so ein bisschen zu weit, dieses A,
Waffen sind aber doof und ich hatte auch, das ist auch so ein Punkt wenn ich
mit Leuten spreche, ich habe vor einer Woche mit einem Bekannten gesprochen,
der Er auch sagte, ja, aber jetzt mal so sein pazifistischer Blick.
Warum ist es so schlimm?
Warum stellen sich die Ukrainer da so quer und sagen nicht, dann haben wir halt
eine andere Regierung? Weil es wird doch eh alle paar Jahre gewählt.
Und so anders ist das doch nicht, als wenn jetzt einfach, weißt du,
wie wenn eine Wahl wäre und eine andere Regierung, dann ist jetzt halt Putin der Regierende.
Dann hätte ich gesagt, ja, aber du hast schon Butcher mitbekommen und Mariupol und nö.
Ja, weil Nachrichten guckt da nicht so, Weil das macht so schlechte Laune und sowas.
Und das ist dann wieder der andere Aspekt. So Leute dürfen dann wählen und am
Ende sorgt das, so ist einer der Punkte, warum wir dann wieder schlechter bei
Rüstung dastehen, weil Leute es nicht verstehen.
Aber zurück zu Macron. Ja, ich denke, der...
Die werden jetzt deutlich mehr was machen können.
Und vor allem die und Polen sind ja sozusagen über Deutschland hinweg,
die rechts und links von uns, die spielen immer wichtigere Rollen.
Und wir dackeln immer noch so hinterher.
Und bei Merz, ja, ich bin mir auch nicht sicher.
Also ich bewerte Leute ja immer nach dem, was sie liefern. Und ich meine,
bisher musste er nie liefern.
Das ist immer einfach, weil ich habe auch immer eine Menge Ideen und fordere
eine Menge Dinge. Ich hätte auch Taurus geliefert, aber ich musste es auch nie entscheiden.
Ich bin gespannt. Und dann halt mit so Bremsbacken von der SPD noch nebendran
und mit der AfD, die immer rumnervt.
Aber Merz und SPD, also ich hoffe, dass er was bringt und dass er den Laden
zusammenhält, weil ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, wie es ist, so Kanzler zu sein.
Aber mit der SPD im Boot, also ohne geht es nicht, klar.
Aber ich glaube einfach nicht, dass es die Sache einfacher macht.
Oder wie will er sich deren Gunst erkaufen oder so.
Da sind mir noch zu viele Fragen offen. Also ich befürchte, dass wir zwar so
ein paar Rüstungsaufträge dann schreiben, die dann über Jahre irgendwann mal
realisiert werden sollen.
Und dass aber wir weiterhin vor allem auf dem Papier das Problem lösen,
aber nicht in der Praxis. Also das ist so meine Sorge.
Und wenn wir Glück haben, kümmern sich Polen und Frankreich drum,
dass die zumindest ordentlich aufrüsten und abschrecken.
Und jetzt haben wir halt nur noch Frankreich als Atommacht in der EU,
nachdem die Briten weg sind.
Und sie hatten ja schon gesagt, sie wollen sozusagen uns alle mitschützen mit ihren Atombomben.
Aber das ist halt, ja, hängen wir wieder von jemand anderem ab und hoffen,
dass der uns lange gut gesonnen ist und dass nicht irgendwie jetzt noch eine
französische Regierung kommt demnächst irgendwie, die auch keinen Bock mehr
auf die Sache hat, weil dann wäre es richtig fatal für Europa.
Genau. Ja, ich meine, das Problem haben wir natürlich jetzt generell immer, wobei,
ich möchte nicht sagen, ich bin da optimistisch so weit würde ich nicht gehen,
andererseits glaube ich tut uns Trump in einer Hinsicht einen Gefallen,
man sieht das natürlich jetzt schon überhaupt dass überhaupt erstmal so dieser
Erweckungsmoment dieser Ruck durch Europa geht mit so oh scheiße jetzt sind
wir aber irgendwie auf uns alleine gestellt ist, müssen wir mal was tun.
Das wird auf jeden Fall Folgen haben.
Andererseits zeigt Trump natürlich jetzt auch ganz wunderbar auf,
wie scheiße so Faschismus ist im neuen Gewand und wenn die Geschwindigkeit der
Demontage der USA als Staat so beibehalten wird,
dann wird glaube ich, naja,
also wird nicht mehr so lange dauern, bis da interessante Auflösungserscheinungen zu sehen sein werden.
In wirtschaftlicher Hinsicht, gesellschaftlicher Hinsicht und mal schauen,
in welcher Hinsicht sonst noch so.
Das wird noch ein bisschen dauern, aber man ist sozusagen schon auf dem Weg
und es ist ja auch so, dass man außerhalb der USA das schneller sieht als in den USA.
Man sieht das ja auch jetzt schon.
Ich denke mal in intellektuellen Kreisen ist das Ding jetzt eh schon gegessen,
aber worauf ich hinaus will ist.
Dass so die Lust an Staatszersetzung jetzt durch so Vögel wie Elon Musk nicht unbedingt steigt.
Ja, sodass das also durchaus auch eine Gegenbewegung auslösen kann,
die vielleicht jetzt nicht mega stark ist, aber ausreichend ist,
um zumindest diese Populisten und Russlandversteher und so weiter,
wie die AfD und vielleicht auch den Front National halbwegs im Griff zu halten.
In dem Zusammenhang wundere ich mich, das finde ich auch mal interessant,
ob du da eine interessante These hast, aber wir haben ja nun mit Meloni in Italien
so eine Mussolini-Verehrerin,
so ganz linksradikal kommt sie ja nicht rüber.
Auf der anderen Seite fährt sie in einen interessanten pro-ukrainischen.
Pro-europäischen Kurs mit, so sehr sie auf der einen Seite innerhalb Italiens
halt auch so in diesem Abschiebungs-Antimigrationspolitischen Prozess sich aufreibt.
Ich kann mir aus ihr und überhaupt der Rolle Italiens derzeit irgendwie keinen richtigen Reim machen.
Andererseits hält ihre Regierung schon länger als das normalerweise mit italienischen Regierungen so ist.
Ja, ich verstehe ihre Linie auch nicht, also so grob, also sie ist ja irgendwie
rechts, rechtsextrem ihre Partei, je nachdem, wo man die so ansiedelt, aber deutlich rechts.
Den einzigen gemeinsamen Nenner, den ich immer wieder halt bei diesen Sachen
sehe, ist so sinngemäß ein starkes Italien, was irgendwie eine Rolle spielen soll.
Also so Dinge zumindest ein bisschen in die Hand nehmen, wie halt diesen kleinen
Airwax schicken, wenn die Amis die Runden nicht mehr fliegen,
dass man sagt, hier Italien,
wir haben noch so einen kleinen Airwax, wir tun was, wir spielen,
wir sind eine Nation, die was leisten kann, so in der Art.
Und wenn es dann eben um die Ausländer geht, das heißt die nicht,
die sind eben nicht Italiener, die was leisten, die können weg,
und dass das so ein bisschen die Denkweise ist, aber es passt halt auch nicht
immer, weil ich hatte mir auch so ein paar Entscheidungen angeguckt und dann
waren auch immer wieder Sachen, wo ich irgendwie nicht so richtig drauf schlau wurde.
Aber ja, mir scheint so, ja, halt so das Land,
also ein bisschen wie Trump, nur halt auf einem viel, viel kleineren Niveau
so das Land wieder etwas tun lassen oder halt eine Entscheidung machen, etwas bewegen,
wenn es auch nur sehr, sehr kleine Sachen sind.
Und am Ende, ja, ist da halt, sehr viel kann Italien meist nicht machen,
weil sie ja selber genug Probleme im Land haben und so.
Aber mir scheint das, wo sie halt
können, würden sie gerne mehr eine Rolle spielen, auch außenpolitisch.
Nur sehe ich da auch das Potenzial überhaupt nicht, weil Italien war jetzt in
letzter Zeit nie so relevant dafür.
Aber ja, ich verstehe, sag mal, proeuropäische Rechte verstehe ich eh nicht.
Das ist wie dieser internationale Kongress der rechten Parteien,
wo sich dann Rechte mit den Rechten aus dem Ausland treffen und gegen andere
Ausländer sind. Also rechtes Gedankengut ist für mich immer wieder ein bisschen
schwierig zu verstehen.
Deswegen bei Meloni irgendwie am Ende will sie halt eine Rolle spielen und ihr
Land, aber viel mehr finde ich da nicht, was ich irgendwie verstehe bei ihren Handlungen.
Ja, es ist wirklich schwierig mit Europa. Ich merke das auch gerade jetzt,
wo ich irgendwie so durch Asien Tiger und irgendwie versuche Leuten irgendwie
Europa zu erklären, ist irgendwie gar nicht so einfach.
Ja,
So, okay, ich denke, wir sind jetzt eigentlich mit dem, was ich so auf der Liste hatte, durch.
Mich würde mal interessieren, was du denkst, wohin sich das gerade alles so hin entwickelt.
Wenn wir mal davon ausgehen, dass Trump keine Wände einlegen wird in seinem Verhältnis,
Dass Putin den Stiefel leckt und versucht, mit irgendwelchen Erpressungstaktiken
Ergebnisse zu erzielen.
Ich denke, dass wir beide der Meinung sind, das wird nirgendwo hinführen.
Mit einem sich langsam mehr bewegenden Europa, einer Ukraine,
die eh nicht aufhören wird zu kämpfen, egal was drumherum passiert.
Was würdest du meinen, wohin die Reise gerade geht?
Ja, also die USA verliert ja massiv Einfluss auf der Welt, was ja da so wichtig
ist, weil das eben ihr Selling Point ist.
Also wenn wir jetzt zum Beispiel irgendwo eine Militärmission beenden oder so,
das ist für Deutschland nicht relevant, ob wir in Mali oder in Afghanistan dabei
sind. Das definiert sozusagen unser Land nicht.
Aber die USA, für die ist ja USAID, ihre Armee in anderen Ländern,
all diese Dinge, diese Einflussnahme, das ist ja quasi der Markenkern,
dass sie das haben. Und den verlieren sie jetzt.
Das, glaube ich, wird den USA wirklich lange schaden. Und selbst wenn eine andere
Regierung kommt, dann sagt man ja nicht Schwamm drüber, sondern man sagt,
ja, ja, warte mal, das wird ja jetzt ein paar Jahre dauern.
Und bis dahin, denke ich, werden sich eine Menge alternative Strukturen auch gefunden haben.
Also gerade in der EU, also man merkt ja, wie jetzt in Rekordzeit alle überlegen,
wie machen wir jetzt selber unsere Sachen.
Auch ein so ein Detail nur, wie viele Leute ich im Umfeld hatte,
die sich gemeldet haben und gesagt haben, sag mal, wo sichere ich eigentlich
meine Daten und meine Fotos, wenn ich es nicht in die Google Cloud,
die Apple Cloud oder die Microsoft Cloud packen will?
Also nicht, dass das der große Wurf ist, aber dass so normale Menschen auch überlegen,
naja, das, was die Datenschutznerds seit Langem sagen, schmeißt nicht alles in die Cloud in die USA,
aber wir haben bisher keine, sozusagen nicht auf dem Niveau Konkurrenzprodukte
hier, bin ich auch gespannt, was sich in dem Bereich tut, also auch in so Alltagssachen
für normale Menschen, nicht nur die große Politik.
Dann ja auch, was man sieht, der Tesla-Kurs, wie der unter Elon Musk sozusagen
persönlichem Auftreten leidet.
Also wie eine Person das so zerrütten kann, wenn es eben der Firmen im Haber
ist. Und auf der anderen Seite, die anderen Länder oder gerade jetzt die EU,
die sich so emanzipieren müssen, dann auch die Rolle von China.
Also ich meine, wenn ich Xi Jinping wäre, würde ich die strategischen Popcornreserven
gerade anbrechen, weil irgendwie Russland geht es nicht gut. Die USA zerlegen sich.
Abwarten, einfach abwarten, was am Ende rauskommt. Muss China gerade überhaupt nichts tun.
Und das sind, glaube ich, ganz viele so Dinge, wo sich jetzt wirklich den nächsten
aber Jahren, also fünf Jahren oder so, die Welt neu sortiert.
Und ich denke, dass eine stärkere EU bei rauskommt, also wenn wir es nicht völlig
vermasseln, aber da bin ich schon positiv,
weil wir können ja alles, dafür gibt es ja die EU, dass wir sozusagen die Defizite
der einzelnen Länder ausgleichen und zusammen ein Team bilden,
da bin ich auch sehr positiv,
dass das klappt.
Das wird wahrscheinlich eine Weile dauern, weil der Mindset sich erst mal ändern
muss, also so von klein bis groß, von März bis irgendwelche anderen Leute.
Und dann aber auch die langfristigen Folgen, wo ich gar nicht orakeln kann mit
Sachen wie halt in Afrika oder so Länder, die bisher von USA oder Russland stark abhängig waren.
Also so von Demokratien, die gefördert werden, bis hin zu Diktatoren,
die irgendwie gehalten werden, was das da auch zerrüttet.
Aber ich denke, also so in den letzten Jahren hat sich zwar immer wieder was
auf der Welt getan, aber außer Covid gab es nichts, was dieses ganze System
ins Wanken oder ins Verschieben gebracht hat.
Und ich glaube, dass wir halt an dem Punkt doch sehr klar jetzt sind,
dass wir auf allen Ebenen sehen werden, wie Leute eben nicht mehr diese US-Abhängigkeit
haben können oder wollen oder jetzt doch mal so hinterfragen,
wie es andere lange gemacht haben,
und dass wir halt also schon in einem Jahr eine deutlich andere Welt haben werden,
aber in fünf Jahren nochmal viel mehr und ich hoffe, dass es besser wird,
weil wir sozusagen dezentralisieren, also das Das,
was die Nerds schon immer gefordert haben, dezentrale Strukturen.
Aber ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob das so klappt. Also ich habe leicht positive
Ausblicke für die EU, aber ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob das insgesamt Ruhe in den Planeten bringt.
Ja, eine der jüngsten Axtschläge der Trump-Regierung war ja USAID und auch hier
Voice of America und Radio Free Europe einzustellen.
Unfassbar blöd.
Ja, das sind die Machtprojektionsmittel und um Assets in Land zu bringen.
Also ich meine um Agenten geschickt zu positionieren, das sind solche Machtinstrumente beides.
Und ich dachte mir, also es gibt wohl schon einen Move der EU,
zumindest die Finanzierung von Radio Free Europe zu übernehmen.
Was ich schon mal ganz positiv finde mit dem Hintergedanken,
dass das natürlich jetzt auch eine Gelegenheit wäre für Europa unmittelbar diese
Projekte aufzugreifen.
Also sie werden jetzt bei USAID natürlich nicht die ganzen amerikanischen Spione übernehmen.
Aber wenn sie zumindest erstmal, vielleicht auch das, zumindest die nicht amerikanischen
Leute, sie könnten sozusagen die ganzen Journalisten weiterfinanzieren,
die dadurch jetzt auf der Straße gelandet sind.
Sie könnten die ganzen Ernährungsprogramme aufgreifen. Das ist nicht viel Geld.
Also es ist nichts, was Europa nicht problemlos wuppen könnte.
Und allein nur der Move, dass sie quasi das retten,
mal ganz unabhängig davon, wie sie das dann in Zukunft fortführen,
aber wenn sie, sagen wir mal,
70 bis 80 Prozent dieser Projekte retten und sozusagen Strukturen auch erhalten,
die vielleicht jetzt gerade eben noch bestehen.
Das wäre natürlich eine riesige Gelegenheit.
Mal ganz davon abgesehen, dass sie dann sozusagen von den amerikanischen Farmern
das alles in die deutsche oder in die europäische Agrarwelt rübernehmen mit
hier Hilfslieferungen und so weiter finanziert durch Europastadt in den USA.
Das wäre natürlich eine riesige Gelegenheit, hier voranzuschreiten.
Also ich sehe halt Krisen sind ja auch immer eine Möglichkeit,
viel zu gewinnen, wenn man die richtigen Moves, die richtigen Zeit machen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob Europa insgesamt fit genug ist.
Hab allerdings tatsächlich, muss ich das sagen.
Bei Ursula von der Leyen ganz gutes, ich finde, performt da ganz gut.
Die ist schnell dabei.
Die spielt wirklich eine Rolle in dem Ganzen und eine gute Rolle. Muss man ja lassen.
Das könnte durchaus was werden, wenn man das nutzt. Und wo du Afrika ansprichst,
das ist ja auch so ein Blind Eye.
Nicht nur der Amerikaner, auch der Europäer.
Kein Wunder, dass die Chinesen da so populär sind, weil die Chinesen kommen
da halt hin und sagen, ja, guten Tag, was braucht ihr?
Straßen, Häuser, Gebäude, irgendwie bauen wir auch.
Hafen.
Hafen und so. Also quasi Soft-Power par excellence, während naja,
Franzosen jetzt nicht so ein gutes Bild abgegeben haben, hat ja auch dazu geführt,
dass die Russen es geschafft haben, den ganzen Sahel-Bereich quasi abzunehmen
durch die Revolution der letzten zwei, drei Jahre,
was für die Franzosen ja auch ein riesiges Problem ist,
weil da irgendwie viele von ihrem Uran herkommt, um ihre Tonkraftwerke zu betreiben etc.
Ich will jetzt nicht zu weit ausschweifen. Ich sage nur, es muss sich generell was ändern.
Und wenn Europa klug ist, nutzen sie jetzt diese Schwäche der USA aus und übernehmen,
vielleicht nicht einen Großteil, aber zumindest die realistischen Projekte,
die die Amerikaner gerade einfach fallen lassen.
Ja, das wäre der absolut schlauste Move, wenn man auf der Welt wieder mehr Relevanz haben will.
Bis hin zu den Militärbasen, die Trump jetzt noch aufgeben möchte.
Mal gucken, was da noch kommt.
Die sind ja vakant. Genau. Suchen sie einen Nachmieter.
Wir hätten da was.
Okay, Enor, dann würde ich sagen, belassen wir es mal dabei.
Vielen Dank für deine Einblicke und deine Perspektive da. Wann geht es wieder in die Ukraine?
In einer Woche.
Wo möchtest du dann hin?
Sumi. Gucken, ob es immer noch die visafreie Einreise nach Russland gibt oder
ob sich das jetzt erledigt hat.
Okay, verstehe. Also die Grenzregion zum Kursgebiet, was die Ukraine jetzt leider
hat, wieder zurückgeben müssen.
Alright. Dann alles Gute für die Tour. Wir sprechen dann sicherlich auch bald mal wieder darüber.
Und dann sage ich erstmal vielen Dank.
Tschüss, danke.
Und vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Geht bald wieder weiter. Hier wisst ihr ja.
Ich sage Tschüss und bis bald.